hey guys pete here better call saul is
over
it is definitely we have definitely seen
the final episode
and in my mind it was a very satisfying
conclusion
uh i brought a couple of my friends in
here today and we might be joined by
one or two more as we go so
we could talk about it and sort of uh
see where we landed
i thought i mean i i thought it was a
masterpiece just straight out um i was a
little bit surprised to see
that some of the um you know some of the
comments were on the negative side
but i mean i i kind of get it too
because what i liked about it what
impressed me the most was
just like how completely intentional it
felt
and you know i was i was completely
wrapped up in like each different
stage of the finale you know and every
kind of twist and the way that it you
know the characters like i wasn't
exactly sure what was going through
their heads but
every decision that they made
you know it seemed like it you know it
felt right um
and and you know that's really
satisfying because i like you know tv
what i like about tv i guess is that you
have all this time to develop characters
so you know my favorite tv shows those
are the ones that really use that to
their advantage to make you know
make me feel something and make me like
you know
feel really comfortable with these
people and watching what they do
and you know better call saul puts them
in positions where they're what they're
doing is very kind of uncomfortable and
um
you know challenging and so you know i
really i really appreciated the way it
felt like it knew what it wanted to do
it felt like you know don't worry i got
this just follow me i'm going to show
you how this is going to go down
and then you know it it but at the same
time i guess it didn't
it was it was a lot of it was in my head
you know a cerebral it wasn't as as
emotional as maybe i was expecting or
maybe not even enter as entertaining on
some levels like you know not not in the
way that this show can be at times it
was it was more um
understated i guess might be the way to
say it
but i mean i loved it it was it was just
so satisfying the uh the way that it
played out and um
yeah so i guess that's where i just sort
of where i'm at so i'll let you guys
introduce yourselves
tell me what you thought about it and
then we'll circle back around so go
ahead gail
hey thanks pete so i'm gil from the one
take youtube channel and the sawcast
podcast and i would pretty much echo
everything you just said i thought this
episode and the last few episodes have
been masterpieces
and with this conclusion i think we can
call the series as a whole a masterpiece
and i think with jimmy and kim there
have been times during the series where
i was frustrated by them or disappointed
in them but i never got to a point where
i hated either of them so coming into
the finale i still had a lot of empathy
for both especially kim after her
confession that i wanted the happiest
possible ending for these characters
within the confines of the choices that
they've made and i loved the time travel
motif because it's so appropriate here
they have made choices
taking things away from people that
without a time machine can't be given
back so a happy ending today looks very
different than what it may have looked
like 10 years ago for jimmy or kim
so i think they got to the happiest
possible ending in a way that didn't
feel cheap or sappy
saul had to pay for the crimes he
committed and courtney we talked about
this before going live but bringing
marie back was i thought a stroke of
brilliance
because she means so much to us as
viewers and here she almost acts as a
representative
for all the damage that saul caused
and makes it a lot more personal you
know you can ask what crimes did saul
goodman commit and you can list out the
rap sheet which they did to a certain
extent in this episode but seeing her
made it and getting to hear from her
made it a lot more personal and it
reminds you that there is no happy
ending if jimmy doesn't suffer the
consequences of his actions
and
what i wanted though okay he has to
suffer the consequences but i also
wanted him to sort of get his soul back
i wanted him to take off the saul
goodman mask and become jimmy mcgill
but
what does it take to make that happen i
kept thinking maybe he needs to hit rock
bottom and that's when you decide you
need to get help and i sort of felt like
he hit rock bottom we saw him circling
the drain last couple of episodes he got
to a point where he's getting ready to
strangle carol burnett and i thought
this is rock bottom he let her hit the
life alert button and he's running out
the door
but that wasn't enough he went right
back into saul goodman he won the case
against the united states basically by
getting his sentence down to seven years
but the last thing he needed
was to see the correct behavior modeled
by kim at least that's the way i
interpreted it i think it's a little
more complicated but on the surface once
he heard that kim confessed in a
seemingly
totally unselfish action she has nothing
to gain from that on the surface i think
he needed to see that and i'm sure we'll
talk about that more as we get into it
and i didn't see that coming you know i
never liked framing it as kim needs to
save jimmy but i did always think that
one way or another she would she would
have to be involved if he was going to
be saved and what they showed wasn't
what i expected but in retrospect made
total sense to me so i guess that's the
bottom line for me as i got the ending i
wanted in a totally satisfying but
unexpected way so i walked away
um very satisfied
i want to say happy but even again
before we turn the mics on i was not
sure if that's what i was feeling it was
very bittersweet um so uh very satisfied
with the conclusion
yeah and
i think it was i think there's some
challenging parts in there where it's
like i'm still processing it even like
you know full
what are we like 24 hours later at this
point um
you know there's there's things that i
think that if i go back and watch it in
two weeks or six months
you know i might i might fully interpret
it a little differently um you know
especially because you were talking
about the uh time machine
and and the idea you know
what what i like about that idea is that
it's a silly question it's not pointless
necessarily for the reasons that that
walt says that it that it is but it's
it's pointless because you could always
go back a step further you know what i
mean like if you if you do that thought
experiment
and you think you have the perfect thing
then then why not go one step further
and you know go somewhere else and
change something else you know what i
mean so it you could just go on forever
and you would never be able to actually
you know pinpoint anything
but you know whenever
whenever it came up and whenever chuck
came back i really i really like the
idea of of him being his his answer to
the timing you know jimmy's answer to
the time machine question being that i
would have stayed there and i would have
had that conversation with chuck you
know maybe that would be the thing that
he would change and um you know since
then i've thought of a couple of
different ways that that could play out
too so
i don't want to totally go uh off the
rails here i'll i will let you introduce
yourself courtney why don't you go ahead
and do that
sure hey everyone i'm courtney of
courtney's reviews
uh i also really loved this episode it
did hit me um on a on a deep emotional
level so as a as gil sort of eluded we
were chatting a little bit before
the stream began
and for me it was when seeing marie um
was when the the tears started and
pretty much didn't stop flowing until
the end and i really think it was
necessary um to bring it back a
character that we were so attached to to
remind us of just how heinous his crimes
were so that way we would accept the
ultimate conclusion of him serving time
um so because i i feel like there wasn't
a problem i would say with the show but
like if you didn't watch breaking bad
maybe you're not as familiar with
everything that this character did um in
breaking bad so like reading off all of
the the crimes and having uh marie there
as a representative of that trauma i
think was really really important just
again to really drive that home
and um for me i also really loved the
time travel
uh motif and to me it felt very
dickensian so it almost felt like um
kind of like a christmas carol where he
goes to the past to visit ghosts and
he's visited by three ghosts right um at
that point three men who are dead that
were important to him and um the line
that really stood out to me was in his
conversation with chuck
where chuck says him you know if you
don't like where you're heading you can
always change your path and i think that
was the the realization for him maybe
not at that moment but maybe in
reflecting upon that that you can't
change your past but you can change your
path and that also sort of ties in with
like bad choice roads and good choice
roads and things like that and um yeah i
i have a lot to say about it i don't
want to keep um talking too much right
now but uh yeah it's satisfied it
definitely satisfied it ticked off all
of my boxes
um and met all of my expectations plus
some really enjoyed it great finale
yeah and um you know like i said i i
could see
i could see that some people might not
like this this it almost feels like uh
a second season added on after you know
the the the proper story of better call
saul ended in
609
i could kind of i could kind of see that
i mean i not not because i would agree
with it or or think that this is like
even uh you know like that it would be
quite
close to as good as it is
having had this you know what i mean but
um
it's a it it's a big shift
and you know you brought up a christmas
carol and uh that's one of the first
things that i saw when i was reading you
know peter gould's interviews yesterday
you know he he described it that way he
said you know the three ghosts of of
christmas past
with mike um
mike uh walt and chuck and um that that
i thought that was that was just
fantastic like way to structure this
last
you know episode where
you know i kind of wanted to come back
into i kind of wanted it to come back
from black and white you know because
we'd been there for so long except for
the flashbacks um
but
it's not the way that the story ended
you know it the the color
didn't come back
and so you know it needed to end in
black and white so i like that those
those you know three color scenes three
scenes that were in color
were you know with these with these
other giants that were from the series
and in you know the the way that they
they crossed paths and
helped him you know
maybe not like directly maybe not like
actively in in what was happening in his
story but throughout you know through
that we see how he kind of gets to where
he's going
to make that decision to um you know
finally uh
look at look at what he's done the part
that he's played in it and um you know
try to go in a different direction
so um
let me see i i guess there's there's
quite a few questions here
what i'm going to try to do is i'm going
to you know answer them right and as
they came in but um i'm going to try to
hit on a couple of other things as we go
and if you guys uh feel like that i know
you both said that you can't stay too
long
if there's some things that you want to
get in there just whenever we're doing
this just sort of uh interject those as
we answer the ones that we're talking
about here
so
paradiddle44 thank you for the 10
it has been quite a ride thank you for
all that you do
i can see that being kim and jimmy's
last moment together but assuming he can
receive conjugal visits
i like to think she visits sometimes um
you know the the the conjugal was a
aside uh the
i i thought it was a little bit weird
that they didn't
you know they picked a um
they made up a fictional
penitentiary so we don't really know
um
where he is necessarily i mean i guess
you could say by looking at the yard you
know that they use that that he's
somewhere
you know maybe in the rockies or
something like that but i mean it you
know it it's not really clear if that
that's a one-time visit
you know that or if if that's something
they can do again
and i thought it was a really
interesting choice to have her
you know
because it felt like whenever you saw it
it felt like okay she's a lawyer again
but i guess maybe that wouldn't even be
possible in the amount of time that
passed or something
and she just used her card that didn't
expire so i thought that was an
interesting choice to have her
you know
do that one last little uh
thing where she she snuck in basically
and it really made it feel like maybe
this is the only time they'll see each
other or it won't be a regular thing
either way you know
it's funny how that scene has acted as a
kind of litmus test
because my younger brother adam he
watched the scene and had a very
romantic and optimistic read saying
they're back together that's it they're
going to be as together as possible
given the circumstances
uh i read it differently i i said i
didn't think it was their last visit
together but now that he is jimmy mcgill
again kim calls him jimmy and she can
finally look at him and see a human
being rather than this husk of a person
i figured that she would want to keep
him as a part of her life but at the
same time i do think she's starting a
new chapter she's volunteering at the
legal services place and i gotta think
that that is the first seed planted that
eventually leads to her practicing law
again that's my interpretation but i
could see a scenario where once a year
or every once in a while she checks in
on jimmy i don't see why she wouldn't
but i know a lot of people
did read that as the final interaction
between them so i think it's it's
interesting i've seen the gamut of
different interpretations
yeah and i think it doesn't really
matter in a way i think it what matters
is that it was enough for him like he
didn't feel like you know he made the
wrong choice by
following through with that and um
and and and doing the right thing not
because he was going to get something
out of it not because he was going to
get kim back or because
you know it was going to you know solve
some problem for her even but just
because it was the right thing to do and
then when she showed up
that validated that you know that was
that that little bit of validation that
like yeah that that is an honorable
thing you did it was it was worthwhile
can't really say what's going to come
after that but you know
good on you for doing it kind of thing
yeah i just pulled up i was i was
looking for this because i saved it
earlier um something that ray said about
her take on the end of the show so she
said that um because she's a hopeless
romantic
uh she thinks that
that um this will also apply to how she
handles her relationship with jimmy and
that she's going to go through a very
complicated process of trying to figure
out if she can help decrease his
sentence in a way that is still just and
i don't think that's the last time
they'll see each other not by a long
shot but that's me and i think other
people will think well that's the last
day that's it so i i personally love
that they left it open to interpretation
um i agree that it's probably not the
last time that they they're
gonna ever see each other but i also
would be satisfied if it were
yeah i guess that that's my question and
uh chase is here now so he can he can
join in on this too
um yeah but i guess that would be the
question um
with with the way that it played out
i mean she you know
what i would like to see is i would like
you know for her to like you said gil
just sort of follow up where she was at
um rebuild i mean i think that
you can see that they go in different
speeds you know like whenever we go back
to when we go back to florida which you
know i think she's still there so if you
think about it this prison is definitely
not in florida
it could be any number of places but
it's not in sunny
florida near where she lives so so there
is at least
some sort of boundary in her like
visiting regularly or whatever
um
but yeah you know like where where do
i i
it seems like
you know saul he had this jimmy you know
he had this thing where he could turn in
on an in an instant you know from one
one of his uh personas to the other
i think with kim when we went back we
saw that she you know she she did the
right thing she unburdened herself and
she was willing to take responsibility
for what she did
but it wasn't an overnight thing where
she just
became kim wexler that we knew for for
uh you know five seasons before that
she still had a little bit of a a little
bit of a hard time giving an opinion
whenever they showed her at lunch
but she moved
into volunteering you know what i mean
to to go back to where she might think
that she's okay to help people again
which would be
fantastic
so i kind of want her to just follow
that her own trajectory there even
though at the same time i completely
want them to
be together because i i really enjoy it
when they are i mean not together
obviously he's going to be locked up but
i mean
you know it's like i don't i don't know
how much i really want them to be
focused on each other
whereas you know there's they both have
their own uh their own stuff to deal
with i guess
hey chase are you here
yeah i'm here just listening along
hey how's it going guys
is going good you want to introduce
yourself yeah uh
david kiwi here chase um
glad to uh glad to join in i was just
listening along to the great uh great
opinions you guys had about kim i do
like how they left it open ended i think
you pretty much uh hit the nail on the
head there um i do wonder what's in
store for a character next i don't know
if we'll ever see anything but uh i do
like how they kept it open-ended and i
do think it's interesting how she's sort
of reverting back or at least
transforming into a new version of
herself and starting to be okay with
making decisions again
um i'm not too sure if we ever will see
anything more in regards to this but i
honestly would like to see some sort of
like
el camino esque like kim movie in the
future or something like that uh just
just have to wait and see if they ever
return to the universe or not because on
one hand it does feel like a conclusive
ending but on the other hand there's
definitely a lot more that they could
take this so yeah
either of you guys want to chime in on
that or
should we move on to the next question
well selflessly i would love to see more
but at the same time like i feel like
this was a really great ending i don't
think it's necessary and i would be
afraid that well i don't think they
could ruin anything but i don't yeah i
don't know i need to still think about
it
did you see uh as i know you mentioned
you were reading through the peter gould
interviews today but i forget which
publication it was but there was one
where the first like four questions of
the interview were so you've got to be
thinking about a ken spin-off right he's
like oh no no i don't know you know you
know i didn't see that one it was it was
pretty funny they were pushing really
hard for it
yeah that's cool i mean you know i i
like like
you put it really well you know
selfishly i would i would like to have
that but
you know a good ending is hard to come
by and doing it twice that's you know
twice as hard so
yeah i i want to see as much ray seahorn
as i can can get you know i mean she's
an incredible talent and um
this is a great character but uh
sometimes i mean all good things come to
an end which is the reality of of uh
how this stuff all works um
jackie cavendish thank you for the five
dollars i noticed that jimmy was wearing
a ribbon on the lapel of his shiny suit
any idea what it represented supported
this is um
a breaking bad reference this is uh
wayfarer 515 is that what it was called
anybody anybody
there's a there's a there's a plane
crash uh it's it's it's a very kind of
complicated story for me to uh it's a
big part of season two of breaking bad
um
it has to do with
some of the characters that are in uh
walt and jesse's orbit and their family
and there's a big disaster it's really
intense uh
storyline that's there and
afterwards
saul being the kind of
predatory
guy he is he sees an opportunity to um
you know put together a big case so he
he has some commercials and he wears the
the thing you know in memory of the
people who who died in that that plane
crash
isaac drum thank you for the 20 that is
very generous did oakley blow his shot
at
naming a name for himself
or does saul know that he would be a
cream puff that he can push around um
i don't know i mean i think that's
probably open i think
i think when saul called him he did
think he was giving him the chance to
make a name for himself and he did think
that
like he was right i mean they had them
down to
like it was like life plus
multiple years and they had him down to
seven
to the point where you know i mean he
was just getting exactly what he wanted
and um
you know i think i don't think oakley
did anything i think that um you know he
was fine and doing what he was was there
to do it was just that
uh saul heard that kim uh confessed and
and then he changed
his course and therefore
um
oakley
found himself signed up for the wrong
you know for the wrong team kind of
thing
i don't know
that scene was hilarious when
when he started confessing and you know
he's like i request to withdraw from the
case and the judge was like not a chance
that was so funny
great comedic relief having him there so
yeah i think he was just he really when
when saul calls him and is like you know
you know you hit the jackpot he really
did because like had he gotten off with
just seven years that would have been
you know an incredible win for for
oakley
um
so
he was one of my favorite surprises of
the finale because i really thought that
seeing his picture on that bench with
that and learning he became a district
attorney i really thought that was kind
of our farewell to him in retrospect i
guess it's it feels like this was kind
of telegraphed
and you know so you know of course maybe
we should have expected it but i i
definitely did not think he would be in
it and if he were that he would play
this bigger role
and it was really nice seeing him again
yeah he was sort of like the co-lead of
the episode
you know what i mean like he was the
wingman in
in like most of uh saul
jimmy's story um
great opportunity for him you know
it's really cool
okay let's see here uh
abraham thank you for
737
peter gould said by the time you finish
watching bcs
you're going to see a breaking bad in a
very different light
according to you
how different is it
um
i'll let you guys go first here
and you just do like a uh one after the
other down the line what do you how
different is it for you now that you've
seen the whole of breaking or better
call saul
yeah i'd say for me i kind of see it
different in two ways
one the kind of obvious way is that now
we know so much more about the person
underneath saul goodman so anytime he's
on screen there's going to be a sort of
dark cloud where you know that there's a
little jimmy mcgill trapped in inside
the subconscious of this scumbag
so his scenes are all going to be a
little sadder but i think the other way
it changes it for me is that not only do
we look at saul differently but this
show also gave us another perspective to
look at breaking bad through we can now
look at it through saul goodman's
perspective and how he sees those events
the fact that he sees himself as pretty
instrumental in walter white's rise in
power
and i don't say sees himself that way
because i don't think it's it's true
clearly he was an important factor in
that but when breaking bad wrapped up i
never would have thought of it in those
terms as you know this was all thanks to
saul goodman but now we see that he
views it that way and i can see it from
that perspective and of course that's
very important to understand the choices
that jimmy's made
but
yeah so for me the bottom line is i look
at saul differently and now i feel like
i also have the ability to kind of put
on my saw glasses and view the series
through his eyes
yeah well uh to piggyback a little bit
on what gil said of course you see salt
differently and uh we have that that
different perspective but um you know
when they kept teasing like how like the
end was gonna change the way we saw it i
was it are my fee was already changed so
uh leading up to the premiere of the
second half remember how they did the
breaking bad marathon so i was watching
some of those older episodes and i
realized how differently i saw mike in
particular and so having all that back
story about his son and his relationship
with nacho gave all this new context to
his relationship especially with jesse
and also getting to know uh gus better
as well so some of these other
supporting characters from breaking bad
i have a
deeper appreciation for and also the
salamancas of course and um and uh
the cartel in general so
my my the way i see breaking bad was
already changed so and then this idea of
seeing how
jimmy became saul and it being the
breakup that was really the the tipping
point for him
um
i don't know that it radically changed
the way that i saw it i was expecting
something like that certainly as we we
neared the end of the series
but uh it certainly makes it sadder so
i'll i'll have to think about that
question as i rewatch breaking bad um
and and see how i view saul's behavior
and actions and see that colored through
the trauma of what happens in these
final few episodes
they really um
did just hang a little bit more tragedy
on every element of breaking bad any
scene in the meth lab now you know that
howard is down there next to lalo for
eternity
anytime you look at the salamancas or
mike you'll think of nacho blue flower
in the rain they just took everything
you know
and now anytime you see it there's just
a little bit more tragedy to think about
that got you there
yeah does it do you feel differently
about walt now that you've seen
uh
this the series and and you've gotten to
know all these other characters that he
destroys
yeah i know he i definitely view him as
a bulldozer like there were lives and
there were all these things happening
and the entire time you're watching
better call saul you just know that the
walter white bulldozer is coming yeah at
the end of all this
yeah that was one of the things that
really popped out whenever kim returned
to albuquerque and you see you know
two years
of
walter white and there's nobody left you
know a lot of them disappeared during
the breaking bat or during the better
call salt timeline the jimmy mcgill
timeline but
you know by the time she went back there
the whole it's all gone you know
everything they built up so many
different things and there were so many
different people involved and they're
just all wiped off the the the landscape
of albuquerque
what do you think chase what do you see
different yeah so i i really love how
much better call saul and breaking bad
really complement themselves and
knowing
the the context of everything that
happens in better call saw i'm really
excited to rewatch breaking bad again
and just notice all the small my new
details um i really love how much they
reference season two episode eight
saul's first episode throughout the
entirety of better call saul but mainly
also just like the final four episodes
or so whether it's the it wasn't me it
was ignacio of it all or uh saul being
the main catalyst for uh what motivated
walt uh to get all these connections
such as gus and how none of this really
would have happened if saul wasn't that
main anchor point to connect all the
docs dots and connect the different venn
diagrams of uh of these characters in
the past that they're that they're going
down and i was i was almost wondering if
uh re-watching better call solar
breaking bad would be a little bit of
like a tragic bummer depending how uh
the show end ended if it was like super
depressing or if it was bittersweet i
think it was the perfect amount of
bittersweet that i can now
go back and re-watch better call saul
and breaking bad and not feel too
depressed about where everything ends up
uh while also being able to appreciate
things in a new way and that's why i
love these series because you know
everything on screen is there for a
reason and every time you watch the
episodes or
whether individually after they air the
whole series as a whole you always
notice new things um that you didn't
before so that's that's one reason why i
love love these shows and there's so
much re-watchability in it and i'm
really definitely looking forward to
going back cause i haven't seen
all of bret you know i've seen chunks
here and there certain episodes um i i
haven't really seen breaking bad ever
since uh after season five came out so
i'm really of better call saul so i'm
really excited to go through and rewatch
everything again now knowing uh the full
context of the uh the entire universe
and also looking at all of these
different side characters that have
gotten so many of these uh these minor
cameos and seeing where they came from
and uh and where they end up and uh
also even el camino too like i i'm kind
of looking forward to going and watching
el camino again um after the the subtle
jessie nods that we got
throughout the end of better call saul
and i uh i took a clip of like the uh
the ed the disappear from uh
from el camino for one of my videos and
i just kind of got carried away and
started watching el camino and forgot
how much i enjoyed it so yeah i'm
definitely looking forward to
re-watching just the entire universe i
wonder if maybe one day we'll get some
sort of chronologically breaking bad the
same way that they uh some people did
chronologically lost i think that'd be
really interesting i don't think we'll
get like i think somebody will
definitely do it
yeah i think that'd be really
interesting to see how that could go
down as well
because lost was a massive that's a
massive edit you know what i mean
breaking bad and and and um
and better call saul
that's that's pretty manageable you know
what i mean for somebody who has some
time to kill they can do that like the
the lost one just blew my mind because
it's like
that's hours i mean so many episodes of
so many seasons and so and it's like
it's like cutting you have to cut
individual episodes and i don't mean to
get derailed here but
that is impressive but as far as back
and sideways
yeah yeah you know and so
i agree with what you guys are all
saying there uh the only thing i would
add before we move on is that as far as
seeing it differently
it's funny how like at the end of um 609
you know i i think it was gil you you
gil uh
me you and um
jim that were talking about that episode
if i remember correctly and we were just
like it's just so much more sad you know
like
it just seemed like breaking bad was
going to be so much more you know of
like just disappointing to see
saul goodman in every one of his scenes
and i thought that that was the the
really
nice thing that the these last few
episodes did was it kind of it kind of
changed that you know because now when
you see him toiling through that you
know he's tortured you know you know
he's uh
you know kind of trying to avoid the
pain and he's just being this this
character in order to to do that now at
least we know that you know that doesn't
go on indefinitely that he he does uh
you know find his resolution in episode
613
brian serway thank you for the 499 how
did you all interpret the moment saul
flick flipped back into jimmy do you
think confessing his sins in front of
kim was his only motivation
i i mean i think that
i think what
one of the takeaways i had from the
finale was that you know you i i guess i
i guess i never really thought about it
that hard but you know
i wondered if if jimmy knew what he was
doing you know if it was conscience i
mean if it was caught if he was like
consciously like making a decision not
to feel those things and be saul goodman
or if it was more of a um
defense you know just like a complete
uh you know sort of
you know like automatic
coping mechanism kind of thing and so i
guess from the finale what i take away
is that he did understand that he
understood what he was doing he just
couldn't stop doing it so i think that
was i think it's you know part of his
motivation is to show kim that he that
he can make the honorable choice too you
know sort of
uh you know i can do that because it's
the right thing to do even though i'm
gonna pay a huge price for it i'm gonna
be in jail for much longer but then also
because he he knew that it was you know
he wasn't going to be able to run from
his past forever and it was it was
killing him and it was it was causing
problems like a cancer throughout the
rest of you know people that were
associated with him uh so i think that
you know he did that for for a chance at
relief even if maybe he he wasn't sure
if he would get it or not
yeah i mean the way the way i
interpreted it is he finally figured out
what he really regretted you know it
wasn't money or the opportunity to to um
further his career it was regretting
what happened with kim
so
i think it was really it was she was the
trigger that made him want to do it into
your your um your point p like he was
already living
not a life too unlike a prison life
right like he was going through the
motions of uh you know
cinnabon and stuff like that but um so
deeply repressed and not able to be
himself and afraid and terrified and
he's a he's a celebrity in jail they
love him right so his life i don't think
is that terrible all things considered
so it's not too unlike what he was
already living but now he gets to
finally be himself he can breathe he's
not looking over his shoulder anymore
yeah and uh one thing i'd add is
something that i didn't notice the first
time i watched it but then her
discussion about it and
i think when he was on the plane right
and he told bill you know i've got some
information at that point he'd made the
decision to confess and i think he
wanted kim to be an audience for it
because he wanted to show her you know
that he can he can change i think you
would have confessed whether or not she
was there
but the fact that she was there there's
a certain point in the scene
when he looks at her and then he takes
the confession a step further because
initially he admits to his role in
everything walt did you know he recants
what he initially said
uh and basically um
admits that he had
he was pulling the strings you know walt
would not have hurt or killed all these
people if not for me and then he looks
at kim and says i have one more thing to
say and he talks about howard and he
talks about chuck and i forget who says
it maybe bill but those aren't even
crimes why did you confess to that
yeah
that was a nice call back to the um you
know
the scene where he's getting reinstated
and
um
at least i thought so like where he
originally when when he lied and
uh
he finally told the truth right right
yeah yeah i definitely love that
parallel a lot we're in season four it's
just a huge ploy in order to get what he
wants but here he's actually being
genuine and honest and it's kind of
interesting too because at first you're
kind of led to believe that he's gonna
talk a bunch about howard and he does
mention howard and he does show you know
sincerity that he feels bad about it
which is really one of the first times
that we've ever seen that he kind of
puts that to the wayside and then he
actually talks about chuck and i'm so
glad that we actually got some sort of
chuck acknowledgement here in the finale
and that he actually got off of his
chest what he did with the malpractice
insurance because that's just the one
the one thing that i didn't know if he
was gonna take it to the grave or not
because you know he didn't he never told
kim he never told anyone else kim acted
out you know towards howard in season
four because she didn't know about it
chuck and howard both died never
learning the truth so at least now kim
knows the truth and he has that off his
chest it kind of
probably seemed to everyone else like it
came out of left field but i really like
how he got that off his chest and it
seems like the moment that he started
talking about howard and chuck he really
he really was jimmy mcgill it's like he
uh he he bloated his ego uh you know
bragging about walt and and all that but
that almost killed saul and now he's
jimmy and i really love the
transformation about you know going from
gene to saul to jimmy all in one episode
i thought it was really quite brilliant
yeah
um
the
there's so much in there that it's just
um
i think that the the i think that we we
pretty much touched on all the the the
biggest parts that
that i i i wanted to to look at but i
mean i think it's one of those things
where there's more
like the more i think about it the more
sort of comes out you know i mean like
i think that he he will
um
it's a process and and you know those
like you guys were all kind of saying
those were the the initial steps and um
you know the
it's it's it's exciting that he can
actually go in a different direction
because it's been so frustrating to
watch him continue to make the worst
kind of decisions for for quite some
time now
brian stairway thank you for the 199. uh
we already touched on this do you think
this is kim and kim's one and only pris
president visit um it's up in the air
but
it it could go either way and i guess we
all said that we liked that you could
you know kind of um
you could kind of choose your own
adventure there do you think it'll
happen or not jim cappell
thank you for the 999.
pete you didn't want to see the
courtroom or saul thriving in prison we
got both
i think it was masterfully done but took
your viewpoint prior to the airing how
do you feel about seeing it play out
well i mean the courtroom thing was more
of a confession
and i thought they set it up really well
so
i didn't mind that at all i didn't even
really think of it
you know when i was watching i didn't
even really think about like oh they're
doing this thing i didn't want them to
do
it it didn't even dawn on me it just
felt like you know completely right and
you know what was really surprising i
think was that he got caught in the the
first
few minutes of omaha you know i mean
like he didn't
they didn't drag that out at all like he
was just instantly in custody so i don't
know how they could have done it in a
different way from that you know
he just
he was it was pretty much set up that
way um
as far as thriving in prison like
that was the one thing that i didn't
like about the episode if i had to pick
like i thought the thing in the bus was
completely
kind of a lot you know what i mean like
i i felt a little uncomfortable when i
was watching it like what is happening
here like this doesn't feel right and
then like kind of the only time that
that happened um i bet i mean i guess
it's fine you know because i guess he he
kind of brings it up at one point about
how
you know so many of the people that were
involved got killed uh you know and
from walt before so i guess maybe that
they had to sort of say look he's he's
going to be okay
you guys don't have to worry about that
even though like i think that was also
kind of obvious because everyone's dead
so i don't know what did you guys think
the the best thing you know it reminded
me of um have you seen dark knight rises
do you remember the scene where they're
chanting as he's climbing
i don't remember that
it's like rise up or something i don't
know that's the reminded me of a little
bit of that
i actually i so i one thing i really
liked about the finale is this little
flavor it gave about what's in store for
the characters you know seeing kim go to
do the volunteer work and and i
personally felt like i needed the
reassurance that jimmy's life is not
going to be an utter hell
uh i wasn't worried that he was going to
be killed in prison or anything like
that but just to see that he is
having as good a time as he can i i feel
like he's getting
like just the right amount of punishment
so so i appreciated that and the bus
scene i was pretty polarizing i saw a
lot of people the word cringe was thrown
around often times in all caps i love
the bus scene
i'll say
every single time i've been on a bus
that was going an extended distance
nine times out of ten we break into song
singing old theme songs or just somebody
starts and and it breaks out i don't
know how often it happens on a prison
bus but i think they've set up the saul
goodman character so well and his
commercials are basically a youtube meme
in this universe i like to think sure no
i feel like the chain gang like always
singing songs like that there is that
tradition of it that you see in old
films and things true so i also i didn't
have a problem with the bus scene i i
think um again they were just trying to
let us know he's going to be okay
he's going to survive in there and more
than just survive he's going to thrive
in there like i can imagine him giving
legal advice you know
and things like that so he's yeah so
they just and let's say he's going to
thrive in there and the fact that
although he now thinks of himself as
jimmy and he's kind of tried to shed the
persona
i don't think the world will necessarily
let him forget and it's not necessarily
the worst thing in the world i don't
think it's going to make his life
miserable or anything but people are
going to continue to call him saul
people are going to want to hear him say
better call saul
it's almost i think peter gould used the
analogy it's like an actor who's so
associated with a role that can't get
away from it and that was kind of in
terms of giving us a flavor for what's
in store for the characters that's kind
of what the bus scene did for me yeah
and it kind of also uh thinking about
jeff and how jeff at first seems so
menacing when he first meets him and it
turns out that he just like idolizes the
guy he's a celebrity
that really comes through with pat
healy's jeff you know i think more so
than the um than uh they were harvey
yeah john harvey but um it seems sort of
like say it come on say it yeah you know
so same thing
so and i think that that sort of uh it
was a little bit for me a little bit of
a callback to that um meeting with jeff
in the mall where at first he's he's
scared and you see him again on the bus
there's a little bit of fear at first
when the guy whips his head around and
he's like he doesn't want to make eye
contact with anyone and then he realizes
that no he's a celebrity they love him
chase what did you think like the bus
scene or didn't like the bus scene
yeah actually i've really warmed up to
it i'm glad to hear uh gil is a defender
of it um
because i don't know i i can't you know
i was pretty indifferent to it the first
time i saw it but i've rewatched the
episode a few times and i really do
enjoy like i'll i'll chant along to it
i'll uh you know i'll hit i'll hit my
computer desk and while i'm watching the
scene and chant along it actually kind
of gets me hyped now and i like the
i because it was either gonna go really
well for him in prison or just
absolutely horribly and i love how at
first they make you think like oh you
know is everyone gonna hate him and then
you realize no they all love him so i i
love how it just goes from one end of
the scale to the other and it bounces
back i love seeing saul kind of smile as
they drive along in the cnn's knowing
that he's going to be all right in
prison it's going to be easy for him to
make friends he's going to you know
possibly pull a shawshank redemption uh
not in regards to escaping but you know
helping everyone with their their legal
their legal stuff in prison um and yeah
so i i really enjoy it it's it's really
grown on me a lot uh
quite a fan for sure
yeah i mean i think you know he's he's
la cucaracha he it was to me i got you
know i mean it just always seemed like
he would he would find a way
i mean i get what you guys are saying
that's all cool
good opinions even though they're you
know wrong but um
no i'm just kidding uh yeah i think it's
i think it's pretty subjective you know
it it it's
it's for me it was just uh
i don't know it just like i said i was
like i was like super um
super dialed in to everything like i
felt like i don't want to keep saying it
over and over again repeating myself but
i just felt like they were like kind of
leading me through the story and that
felt like a weird uh departure you know
the first time maybe maybe it'll seem
different when i see it
later but um
you know i i think uh
it didn't it didn't take me out of it or
ruined it in any way and i think really
to go back to the question that the the
viewer asked
it's a lot different than what i would
have thought though because
as you mentioned
by that point he's not he's you know i
guess what i didn't want him to i didn't
want i guess what i didn't want to see
was him go into prison and be saul
goodman you know i wanted saul goodman
to die
and you know that part of him to be
killed and i wanted you know him to do
that uh on purpose himself make the
decision
and so you know he did that and now
those people still remember him for who
he is and and that's a lot different you
know i mean that's not him
that you know we saw him go from we saw
him punch the door and then we saw him
go from gene to saul there and then you
know he had the he had his he had
himself the sweetheart deal he he had
you know everything was i didn't want to
see him be that person
in prison and you know they we saw the
what happened on the bus but then we
also saw that he's pretty humble it
seems like and they like him they like
to call him saul because that's what
they know but he's not going around like
at least with a little bit we saw and
like you know you know trying to run
things you know trying to to play angles
or anything like that yeah and in terms
of things we've seen him done in the
past that we've seen him do in the past
that he's now doing in the prison we
don't see him going around giving people
advice on how to legal loopholes or how
to corrupt the legal system we see him
making bread like using his gene
tachovic skills rather than his saw
goodman skills
and uh i really enjoyed that
i saw somebody say something like to the
effect of he's always been about that
dough you know
it was money then it was cinnamon rolls
and and now it's uh bread and i don't
get it so you have a problem with the
bust scene but it's all about that dough
that you love i mean that made me laugh
in the comments when i saw that you know
i can't say
uh yeah so roger rubio thank you for the
two quite a ride enough said
i'm about to sneeze sorry
um
kenny jaworski thank you for the 4.99
the way jimmy faded from her view as she
looked back it sure seems to me that kim
is moving on and won't be visiting him
in prison
yeah i think it's so i think it's uh you
know it's up
up to interpretation um
the the door is oh the door is there if
she wants to open it
um i i guess we kind of already talked
about this so
just for me i i i like to think that
it's there and if she gets to the point
where she's ready for that then um
he's not going anywhere so that'll be
okay i actually find the fact that she
looks backwards kind of hopeful right
like if she had been looking forward i
think that would have been a more overt
way of saying she was moving forward and
not looking back
[Music]
yeah i mean it it felt like they they
were saying it felt like you know it
the way that they the way that they
framed it and the way that they followed
her it was
it was it was trying to to invoke the
her doing the um the the uh
finger guns at the end of season five
you know what i mean because that became
such an iconic thing in between seasons
and you know she's looking and and you
know that she's thinking about him and i
think it you kind of have that is she
gonna do the finger guns too like and
i'm really glad that that she didn't
that it was just uh it's just left as
you know she looks she she looks until
she can't see him anymore and then
you know that's where that's where it
comes to an end
almeida's army thank you for the 449
pound in my super chat last time i had
three predictions skyler marie and chuck
would show up
as the song play as the song says two
out of three ain't bad thanks for
everything
yeah um i i have to say
you know p a lot of people thought
skyler was gonna come back and um i saw
marie's name tossed about but i never
really considered her playing a part in
this if if i'm being honest it's sort of
like bill oakley like
the idea was out there that he would
he's he's become a defensive uh you know
he's he's he switched sides he's um not
a prosecutor anymore
but it just seemed like it would be
really hard to make that work um him
being his
being is so involved and and marie i
mean these guys have already said that i
didn't uh really chime in and i just
agree with what they were saying it was
a it was a great addition it really did
um for a character that i didn't think
about that much
you know like i mean i liked the the
performance i liked uh you know the
actor uh but not not essential when i
think about all the all the different
characters in this universe and
man she really uh she really
brought something to the finale that i
wasn't expecting and chuck you know i
kind of came around to the idea that
he should show up because he's so
important and
i i was i was i couldn't have been i
think that was probably my favorite um
you know kind of payoff of things that i
was expecting to see happen and uh
i really uh i'm really glad they did
that i i think i heard in the in the
insider podcast um
peter gould said that they they weren't
going to do that that they actually
added it after the fact whenever they
you know when they were looking at the
how you know how it was going to be
spaced out or something like that and um
man it would have been a totally
different episode if he wouldn't have
been involved
yeah that that's fascinating to me for a
couple reasons i mean first i'm just so
glad they decided to bring him in
because i was hoping i wasn't sure if we
were going to get it but i was really
hoping for a chuck appearance
because i felt like of course he needs
to be acknowledged in the finale but i
would love for them to find a way to
show him one more time
and but why it's so interesting to me
that they added it late in the game uh
just logistically is because it so well
complemented the mic
and walt scenes with the time travel
motif and regret
but also the actual book so now that
book carries so much more meaning and we
saw it in the cold open
and we saw in the carrot and stick
episode on the nightstand so i wonder if
that was originally just intended to be
a fun thing like look hey here's this
book
but this adds so much more meaning to it
yeah yeah i uh i was actually so
surprised that we actually saw marie i i
actually thought back to when we were
talking uh during a previous live stream
about uh whether we'd see skylar marie i
definitely thought it was more likely to
see skyler i guess she took that deal so
it makes sense why we don't see her why
we didn't really need to or she didn't
need to be involved in uh in the court
scene but i was i was really surprised
like seeing marie i out of all the list
of you know the main cast of breaking
bad characters she was probably at the
bottom of the list that i was expecting
to see especially in the breaking bad
timeline um i believe we got a name drop
of her in a 503 a better call saw when
hank and gomi were talking um before
they go and see crazy eight but yeah
that was really surprising and honestly
like i love the actor that plays marie
but i was never really a fan of her
character in breaking bad but i gotta
admit she just absolutely killed it in
this final episode and i i was really
happy to see her i thought i thought it
fit really well um she did kind of paint
you know hank uh in uh too much of a
good light i mean you know don't talk
ill of the dead and she and he is her uh
her late husband um but you know hank
hank was a great guy but he wasn't
perfect just like kind of you know
everyone on this show um but
you know obviously you're gonna remember
the good things about him and i really
love how uh
uh gene mentions how that he saw he met
her he met him multiple times and that
was like a huge uh theory for breaking
bad because when we see
them talk about or when we see saul and
hank talk in breaking bad in season two
episode a we always wondered if that was
the first time that they ever met and
then we find out in better call soul
that it wasn't and we do find the first
time that they ever met and uh how hank
you know figures out his sal goodman pun
name instantly and in regards to in
regards to truck i'm really happy that
we saw chuck in the finale i've wanted
to see him all season long even all
throughout season five we saw him twice
in season four i believe we didn't see
him at all in season five and then just
uh near you know the back half of the
final episode to season six so i'm
really happy that we got to see him uh
honestly like
i
i was going into the finale feeling like
i'd be a little bit disappointed if we
didn't see him i didn't really think it
was going to happen but it was one of
those things that was kind of on my
bingo card of if this happens it'll make
my day um
i i kind of wish that the scene chuck
was a bit longer but i think that's the
point because that's the thing that if
jimmy could go back with a time machine
that he would change she would have that
heart to heart with chuck and so i i
love that um honestly and i i'd say
there's so many there's so many little
tidbits of uh of that scene which truck
from the
front from from the apples to the big
bag of ice to uh
to hiring someone else so there's so
many little easter eggs so that are
throwbacks to the first season and i
love every second of it i think malcolm
mckean just slid back into the role
amazingly i think it was interesting how
he actually like really wanted to talk
to jimmy and jimmy just wanted nothing
to do with it so i don't know i really
love the truck appearance too
yeah i thought they did that pretty
smartly too because they they let it
they played they kind of played both
sides of it you know they they made him
warmer they made it they they kind of um
you know they kind of made him the one
that was was lonely lonely and that he
wanted to you know have him there just
you know just
two brothers talking and having a
conversation but there was also the
underlying thing that he's like you know
maybe you could change your path like
that he was still had that that going on
that he probably still wanted to talk
him out of being a lawyer because
you know it literally dr
drove him crazy you know it made him
feel insane to think of jimmy out there
with a law degree but you know it that
you know but it added some humanity and
um
you know it it there's it's it's kind of
weird because
i think before that i would expect that
if if he was reaching out to him in that
way that that that jimmy would be
receptive but the way that that scene
plays out he's busy you know he's he's
doing that on his on his way to doing
something else and
he he really looks at it like why would
we do that you know why would we sit
here and have a conversation you know it
doesn't really
it doesn't really um
it doesn't really work for him like he
doesn't really he doesn't really see the
point of it so i thought that was all
pretty fascinating and like he said
there are so many references in there
like the whole thing is like a callback
to something else that happened in their
relationship
mm-hmm yeah i really i really like to
how um how he's just clearly grasping at
straws trying to find excuses to have a
conversation it's like it's like you
know he doesn't actually talking about
jimmy's clients isn't actually the
reason he's just looking for an excuse
to start a conversation and i like how
jimmy says oh are you just gonna you
know give me a hard time for the things
that i do wrong and chuck's like no no
that's not what i wanted to do at all
but then just moments later like a
sentence or two later he starts giving
jimmy a hard time about oh i hope that
you didn't steal that ice from a motel
like i know you always do
so he he just can't help himself and i
find that really funny how jimmy totally
called that
it's also just it's so
um
just tragic to think about the scale of
his scams that there was a point where
the worst chuck would say about him at
the moment is he's stealing ice from
motels
and just how it's spiraled since then
yeah i love that that he said that i
hope you didn't take that from a hotel
and it's like of course he did of course
he did he explains that to ernie later
on in the series
jim capelle thank you for the 9.99 when
saul played the victim initially i fully
believed the performance and thought he
was in fact fearful for his life
anyone else get duped by bob's
incredible performance
um
yeah i mean i didn't think that
i didn't think that he did everything he
did because he was afraid of walter
white because they you know they made
that
they kind of had that scene with mike
earlier where they showed that
mike told him leave that guy alone he's
nobody he's going to you know he's going
to be gone and
and and saul saw the opportunity and he
thought he saw that as you know
something he could work with um
but yeah the performance was amazing i
mean it was it was absolutely and he's
done that before i mean they were
talking you guys brought up winner you
know episode 410 before when he does
that he even tricks kim with his crying
and and yeah that was a great uh you
know kind of
like not only is bob odenkirk an
incredible actor but he plays this
character jimmy mcgill slash saul
gene who was also
able to do some incredible acting
in the process of you know doing
whatever he's doing
yeah i agree i i think it was you know
we've seen him do this before where he's
able to do people um but going back to
um to the episode that you were you were
just referencing pete when they go back
inside of the rv and he's looking around
and he's just seeing dollar signs you
know he's seen opportunity uh everywhere
he's excited as he's trying to figure
out who they are and what the operation
is and how much money can be made so um
that was of course playing in in my mind
but again like as he even says he just
needs one juror wonder because it's not
so much on like you know his it's not so
much his or or oakley's uh the onus
isn't necessarily on them to prove his
innocence as much as it is the state to
prove his guilt and as long as they're
able to raise any doubt you know and
that was what that whole little
performance was like he's really good at
raising doubts
one thing i loved about his performance
is that it was
somewhat understated
especially considering how long we've
been waiting for the real confession
you know you start to think he's gonna
sob and just totally break down but i
think the way he played it was so
perfect i mean this is how jimmy wood
would do this
and i especially noticed it when he
mentions howard and it almost seems like
it's too painful to talk about he only
says as much as he can you know what
happened to howard and then he kind of
trails off and you see his lip quiver
and just
that moment really stuck out to me as
just brilliant work from bob odenkirk
yeah and it's funny because
you know he's been the anchor of the
show but the things that he the things
that they have him do are all pretty
subtle you know i mean they don't
they're not like generally you know
he'll have one or two big big scenes
throughout a season and you're reminded
of just how how insanely good he is
but like you know a lot of the times
when you're talking about stuff you're
usually talking about the other
characters and the way that those
people stepped up in their roles you
know what i mean so it it i i did also
like the fact that they that he had this
little showcase at the end i mean
obviously
the whole cast is stacked and there's
not really any weak you know weak links
and and that at all but i mean you know
it felt it felt good to just sort of ha
let him
you know kind of put all of his talents
on display in the in the last name
because you know he is the leading guy
here you know
i mean i definitely i definitely love um
how when he plays the sympathy card and
the victim card during the plea meeting
that marie and the federal prosecutor
instantly know what he's doing and
that's why they call him out like oh you
really think that's gonna work you think
the jury's gonna buy that and then the
second that saul kind of drops the act
uh the the score in the background
starts getting sinister and and he start
he his demeanor instantly changes from
being sympathetic and a victim to being
like oh i only need one juror to believe
me and then to parallel to season four
again um back in season four he was
going to read chuck's letter and then he
saw it wasn't working
so then he switched it up and he was
more genuine and that ended up working
where in this episode if you would have
just stuck to the script that would have
worked and switching it up and
subverting our expectations again is
actually kind of what screwed him over i
mean he did it on purpose he threw
himself under the bus on purpose to you
know get all that off of his chest but i
find find it interesting how in season
four he switched it up and it worked and
then here he switched it up and he
really just you know blew his whole plea
deal out of the water
christopher walker thank you for the
five dollars so which show is better
breaking bad or bcs i think i'm going to
go with breaking bad what do you guys
think
um i mean it's it's two different things
it's two different things like they're
two different styles but
it's all one
it's all one part of a big like a bigger
thing
it's hard you know it it would be hard
to to say like i i certainly like
a lot of things about better call saul
better you know i more i guess uh i like
i like the more
you know than than
like you know
breaking bad it was it was really high
intensity and um
you know it was really impressive in the
way that it it did those things
but that's not really my preference you
know i kind of like i i kind of feel
more surprised
and you know in in
in sort of like uh i don't know like in
an artistic way maybe
with um better call saul whereas like
you know with with breaking bad i was
just like you know just just blown away
and and sort of like along for the ride
i i think as far as the endings i i
definitely like um
i definitely like the better call saul
ending uh better as far as like you know
as far as like how i think about it you
know like i have some problems with with
the way that the breaking bad ended but
i mean breaking bad was so entertaining
when i watched it it was like after the
fact or i started like things started to
like not really you know add up in some
some areas and like this one is sort of
the opposite like this one is sort of
like i i felt satisfied and and it grows
on me more and more
but you know
so it's really hard to to make a
one-to-one comparison
yeah any of you guys want to want to
jump in on that and it really depends on
the rubric that you are using to to
assess them i i no no offense
christopher this is nothing personal
against you i just i typically don't
like questions like that like what's
your favorite book or what's your
favorite movie or what's better because
um they're all different
right so uh in some ways breaking bad is
better in some ways better call us all
is better i think again it depends on
what you're talking about now which do
we like better is a different question i
think and i don't know if that's
like which did you like better and again
i'm kind of i'm that's a hard one for me
to say because i love both but i will
say this i think what this one does
really well is um in-depth character
development and i felt more
emotionally invested in these characters
than i did in the breaking bad
characters so if you are into character
driven story then um better call cell
might be the better option for you but
if you're more into plot and action than
breaking bad hands down right
yeah and i think like if you're really
into that then you should um
you should really consider just watching
feature films
you know i mean like
the the i mean i don't mean to say that
like you know
i'm just saying that one of the things
that tb can do
better than than other mediums like i
said earlier is that they can really
develop characters so when you have a
show that's doing that and that's really
kind of uh you know just getting lost in
that and really really doing a fantastic
job like taking advantage of that thing
that they have there to work with
um it's it's it's a you know it's
something that
i i would love to see that you know more
people be able to pull it off on this
level you know
yeah i think i second pretty much
everything that both of you have said
and i will say that oftentimes when i
ask myself that question just for fun
what did i like better personally a lot
of times i want to say better call saul
and of course there's the bias of that's
what i'm watching right now that's
what's top of mind but if i try to kind
of reverse engineer and see where is
that feeling coming from i think
courtney it's what you were saying which
is that
i feel so fascinated by jimmy mcgill kim
wexler chuck mcgill i'm so intrigued by
these characters and care about them so
deeply in a way that i i won't say i
didn't with breaking bad i certainly
felt a degree of the same thing but i
don't think with breaking bad or with
anything else i've ever felt it as much
as i did with better call saul so i
think that's where it comes from for me
having said that the plot action stuff i
mean there is something to be said for
that the pilot of breaking bad pulls you
in
so quickly and so strongly and i
remember the the moment where
uh wall where victor says to walt you
know you have to meet gus here bring
this one hour and he's scrambling and
then gets the call that the baby is
being born i remember saying after that
episode i have never felt that level of
suspense in my life
and i don't know that a feature film
could necessarily pull it off because of
the character development if you spend
that many episodes connecting with with
walt and these characters and then you
have that scene it just ramps up the
tension in a way that i hadn't felt
before so i think both of the shows have
so much to offer and even if you drill
down to the subtext level they're both
saying different things about similar
themes so they complement each other
really well
but having said that you know courtney
i'm similar to you where
that what this made me feel for the
characters and the discourse it allowed
me to have about the characters the way
they intrigued me i think that
at times puts the show above breaking
bad for me and last thing i'll say is i
am planning to rewatch breaking bad you
know over the next few months and it's
been a long time for me so that'll
probably help me
meditate on that question a little bit
more
yeah so
i
i i honestly feel a combination of both
of what courtney and gill have said
because on one hand there is the recency
bias that is definitely thing um you
know when when we watched episode 603
and then episode 607 we're saying things
like oh it's you know almost as good or
even better
than uh
ozymandias and
it's like i'm not sure if that's true or
not if that's just the reason c bias
talking but then it does have to do with
well what do you like do you like down
to earth more grounded uh character
studies uh you know character uh
development and focus shows or do you
like something on more of a grandiose
scale where in breaking bad you know
death is constantly around the corner
they're constantly trying to get out of
a stressful situation how are they going
to get out of this one who's going to
die next what's going to happen um you
know p death is constantly a threat on
that show where that's not really the
case with better call saul and i really
do think that better call saul is more
late relatable because it's more
grounded and it's more down to earth and
the way that you focus on the characters
and better call salsa i mean you still
do in breaking bad but the way you focus
on it so much more in my opinion better
call saul makes it that much more
relatable whether you're you know
thinking of the the sunk costs with uh
with kim or whether you're just watching
a bunch of silent scenes of mike you
know doing uh you know retired uh
retired detective work um
and the thing with breaking bad is you
know you have scenes like when mike is
just being a straight up badass walking
into that building shooting people left
and right shooting that guy through the
drywall based off of where chao has his
hands in the air um moments like that is
is what breaking bad is to me and i
really love both shows for different
reasons um
i really wonder what i'm gonna think
like right now i think i'd have to
choose better call saul but maybe a year
from now maybe five years from now once
i rewatch both shows i'm really curious
what i'll say then once the uh better
call solo recency bias is aside um yeah
i guess only time can tell but
definitely think these shows will will
age well and i'll have a lot of
re-watchability for the future
yep
great well on that note i i have to to
um step out but uh it's been so much fun
uh chatting with you guys um on some of
these episodes thank you so much for for
having me pete uh yeah that's been great
yeah yeah thanks for coming out and um
you know maybe
i i don't think that there will be any
more better call saul streams but maybe
uh things will line up again and and
we'll
we'll be into something that's going on
that uh we can
get together and talk again on on the
air i'm sure we'll talk
normally uh you know just whatever like
we have been but um it's been great
having you on
lucky luckily for me your fans uh
came in and
uh introduced me to your content and uh
it all worked out so
hope that uh
you know whatever you do with your
channel that turns out good and that
you'll be doing more content and uh
thanks again see you oh and thank you
all for watching and uh nice to um meet
all of you um including you uh gillan
and uh and chase and i'll be seeing you
all on the interwebs i'm sure
talk to you soon
all righty uh john baptist thank you for
the two internally i was begging for the
splash to color
yeah i was but i i'm glad that they
didn't do it um
it made sen i i think it was it was
pretty perfect how it was just the
cigarette uh giancarlo viscanti thank
you for the 20
that's generous
let me start by saying thank you all for
your amazing work have you considered
doing breaking bad recap and review
videos
be awesome to keep this community and
your high quality videos um thanks again
yeah i'm not sure i i mean i i like
everyone has been saying i'm i'm sure
that i might get around to doing a
breaking bad re-watch
it's a little bit difficult to do like
specific um
you know specific videos on that i think
that they would i don't think they would
do very good
algorithmically
if there was a project
you know maybe a patreon thing or you
know a couple people wanted to get
together and do it that that might make
sense
but um
just be just like logistically i i don't
know if it would make sense to go back
um
and and and you know do those videos
because they're not they're not topical
right now
if that makes sense
any of you guys thinking about doing um
breaking bad recap
we're um
i think so i mentioned i'm going to be
re-watching it i think on our podcast
sawcast we'll probably chronicle that uh
i don't know exactly what it's going to
look like yet and that's the nice thing
with that with a podcast yeah i can put
in a couple of hours to talk about the
experience of watching it it's not a
video that needs to be written and
edited and everything i think probably
will do roughly one episode per season
talk about the major events talk about
how it felt watching it after better
call saul so uh it won't be a pete
pepper's video gene carlo but as a
silver lining it might be uh at least a
little bit of a substitute you know to
um
to help you uh
not have that so yeah i i could see
doing something like that um it would be
a lot of fun but um
yeah
like i said it
it's not really it's one of the things
that you know it's kind of a bummer
about
youtube sometimes is you just can't
if you if you need to make a living then
you can't just do always do the things
that that that sound like the most
interesting things to do at that moment
because um
the algorithm and what people are
looking for
really uh is what pays the bills you
know it's not not good ideas the
algorithm starts to seep into your brain
so so even if i'm talking to somebody oh
you got to check the show out i got to
first do the math and say well if i
watch that show am i going to talk about
it on the channel why am i going to
watch it then and that's the worst is
when it starts to affect that so
jeremy chase were you doing any breaking
bad stuff
oh uh yeah yeah i'll definitely be doing
breaking bad and better call saul stuff
uh
uh and then i mean
he was asking like specifically if
you're gonna do episode recaps
uh yeah yeah probably honestly i have i
have in mind to do uh retrospectives for
for breaking bad episodes i won't just
be exclusively doing breaking bad you
know i'm going to be doing other shows
too but i definitely have a lot of
content for uh for breaking bad planned
it and the thing about the algorithm is
i mean breaking bad is kind of a
timeless show right like even during the
off season in between season five and
season six i better call saul i saw
randomly recommended to me like a lot of
breaking bad videos from creators i've
never seen before with hundreds of
thousands of views so breaking bad is
definitely one of those shows that is
timeless and i feel like people will
always watch a video on breaking bad um
just because of how how you know it's
impacted pop culture um
so i i don't know definitely definitely
uh going to keep that in mind i'll
probably do a channel update here in the
near future next week or two uh going
into that more so if people are curious
but yeah
all right jeremy thank you for the 199
what is jimmy's biggest regret
the truth
i mean
you know
as far as what the episode
told me it was what happened with chuck
and
uh how that sort of led to
everything and and kim being involved
and
everything going downhill i i don't know
if you can pinpoint something i don't i
don't i think it's sort of like the um
i think it's sort of like the question
itself you know that's the that's the
flaw in that question of what would you
do if you had a time machine because you
could always go back a little bit
further or find something else that
might be
more effective
to undo
well i think that i think that it's a
kind of a two-part answer because with
uh with with mike's conversation it's if
you could go back and change something
what would be in with walt it's what you
regret so i think the thing that jimmy
would go back and change
is uh messing with chucks and chuck's
insurance and then the thing that he
regrets is not staying and having that
heart-to-heart with chuck during that
flashback so that's just what i got
based off of uh the episode
do you want anything gail or uh no i
think p my answer is probably pretty
close to yours where i i think
if you were to ask jimmy and he was in a
genuine mood where he wanted to answer
it i'm not even sure he would know quite
how to answer he
especially when he's been involved in
scenarios that ended in in people dying
his mind would probably go to some of
those things first the uh insurance with
chuck
everything that happened with howard and
then if he tried to reverse engineer it
and get back to where did all the start
maybe he would think about the first
time he stole from his father in wolves
and sheep and then you get into nature
versus nurture and say well didn't jimmy
have to go through all these things to
become who he is now
so it's it's a thought experiment it's
an interesting one i know a lot of
people like to interpret that maybe the
moment he would choose is the one where
he spoke to chuck and i like the way
peter gould described that as kind of
two
two ships passing in the night where
that was a rare moment where chuck was
maybe willing to open up a little bit
have a genuine conversation
but jimmy wasn't and maybe there would
have been a time where jimmy was open to
that but they they missed each other
yeah
right usually usually it's flip fl
usually it's always the other way around
right so it's really interesting seeing
the contrast and just had to my point i
was saying about the insurance and then
talking to chuck i think it's
interesting how when jimmy or saul
answers walt and mike he kind of gives
like phony answers and then the episode
kind of gives an honest answer in an
indirect way like they don't just come
out and say it but they i think they
heavily imply it so i think that was
pretty cool
jim cappell thank you for the 9.99 last
one i swear
you can ask as many as you want
you don't have to feel bad about that
i totally got choked up and shed a tear
when they fired up that final cigarette
tv hasn't made me cry for years well
okay nacho nacho's final stand got got
me two
anyone else
water works
uh i mentioned this earlier
uh you know for me i i didn't i was
expecting it to come but it never really
did um
i thought that you know i i i thought
all the all the moments hit but
i didn't get i didn't get emotional um
what were your guys's experience
well i was watching with my brothers so
even if i were feeling like i was uh
water works i wouldn't be allowed to
display it in the room but i definitely
had the uh lump in your throat like
there was there was definitely emotions
there uh it didn't get me to the point
of you know sobbing in front of my tv
but
i think i definitely felt what peter
gould was hoping that we would feel
watching the episode it was pretty
emotional
i i feel like uh
i don't know it's kind of weird because
back in the day i feel like i would uh
is a little bit of a tangent here i feel
like uh on one hand i would uh always
get really uh scared of horror movies
but then i would never really get
emotional to anything involving
entertainment now i'm the complete
opposite now you know i love horror
movies it's probably my favorite genre
but nothing really scares me but and
then on the other hand i really do get
choked up at a lot of scenes and uh i i
don't think you know you should be
ashamed to uh to tear up or cry or feel
emotions um if you're watching certain
entertainment and uh that being said i
didn't uh shed a tear in this episode
but
um i was just on the edge of my seat the
whole time i thought the episode was
really intense you know the feeling of
this is the last time we're ever going
to see
a new episode of better call saul a new
scene with this character or that
character um so i was really immersed in
the episode and just in regards to the
uh the scene with the with the cigarette
not just the parallel of them standing
against the you know it's shot the same
way with them standing uh leaning
against the wall and then jimmy taking
the smoke but even the score like it's
the exact same song that plays in the
background as uh one of as the first
episode and then also even the little uh
the little sound effect when jimmy takes
the cigarette and the score almost kind
of skips or it sounds like it's being
reversed to kind of signify that jimmy
is taking the sticker and then putting
it back they put they did that same
sound effect in this episode too so that
that kind of got me right in the feels a
little bit i really love that it was
really immersive
yeah i i i think that that that what
what i've noticed because i i mean
like you said i get i get choked up or
you know misty-eyed or whatever all the
time whenever i watch television it
seems like it happens more and more like
the older i get somehow but the
the thing about the
i think last last week it really hit me
that you know the the scene on the bus i
mean that was
that was the biggest most cathartic kind
of like
you know
heaviest
scene emotion emotionally and
i just i was so wrapped up in what was
going on and what was happening with the
character and and
it i just didn't connect it with it in
the same way that i do sometimes like
where you let your guard down and you
just you're just feeling what what's
happening
and i thought that the finale i i kind
of thought that happened again where i
was just like um
it's just sort of like so just so
like wired into what they were doing and
and and so invested to find out how it
was gonna work out and
that you know like i i didn't i wasn't i
wasn't relaxed enough to kind of just
feel like what what was what was going
on like but i mean i agreed too what you
were saying go like i definitely
i definitely experienced the motion it
just didn't it just it wasn't
overwhelming in in the way that it can
be sometimes
three times that i was overwhelmed with
this show i was just thinking while you
were talking um
one has to be when uh irene runs away
crying from bingo uh like i rewatched
that for my season three tier list
recently and i'd i definitely teared up
when i watched that like that's a hard
scene for me to watch like and i love it
so much it's one of my favorite moments
of the show but it is just so hard and
then the second one has to be uh end of
episode 401 when jimmy you know that's
your cross to bear and then you see
howard's face that's really hard to
watch too and then probably number three
is a nacho's death that that really
choked me up too
yeah i think of this season is probably
nacho
nacho was probably the uh
the biggest um
the one that you were just like whoa
the judo joker thank you for the five
dollars favorite shots from the finale
mine was jimmy disappearing from behind
the wall from kim's perspective
and the fade to credits that was yeah
that was pretty good um i liked even
though it was just sort of a call back i
i liked the exit sign a lot like
hearing the electric hum whenever they
showed that um and the way that that
invoked uh
chuck in his memory um
trying to think of some of the other
like actual just setups and i i like the
overhead shot of him when he was in the
um
when he was still in the gene mode in
the holding cell
i thought that was really cool um
i don't know what about you guys what
are some of your favorite shots
yeah the uh the holding cell that's
where the uh that when he sees the
um writing on the wall that gets the
others
yeah that that's definitely i mean
there's the there's the one that judo
joker points out of course there's them
sharing a cigarette i think those are
the big ones that everyone's talking
about uh but the holding cell was one
that also really stuck out to me it's
such a jarring image
after watching jimmy avoid this fate for
so long and in some sense we've been
feeling him avoid that fate since season
one because we met gene so so long ago
so it was just like wow he's he's
actually that's when it hit me like he
is actually here he is in the legal
system on the wrong side of the law
so that one really stuck out to me
you want to add anything there
chase
oh yeah definitely definitely love the
the cigarette c and i really do love the
uh the finger guns to you i i love how
it's been a recurring trend for the past
three season finales uh start in season
four with a jimmy or saul when he says
saul goodman season five we got kim and
then season six uh at the end we get uh
we got jimmy and er uh you know in in
prison it's really interesting how
uh the finger guns have also been the
final scene between jimmy and kim for
each season so i really do like that
parallel a lot
yeah i didn't make that connection until
right this i mean i i
i looked at it like i looked at both of
those scenes when i was making my videos
and it was right there in front of me
but i didn't i didn't think about the
fact that the last three ones all ended
with finger guns
[Music]
so that's kind of funny um
the uh
yeah i can't think of anything else off
the top of my head i
i i i thought that
maybe um
there was a there was a i'm trying to
think oh you know what it was it was the
one in the uh the mic scene
when he sticks his face in the water and
he comes back up and and it's kind of
that it's kind of a mix of the of the
visual and the the uh the dialogue
though because
mike says
slow down you know you're gonna make
yourself sick and and that just was like
uh you know we had watched we hadn't
seen that actual episode for a long time
like you know it's been a couple of
years since that was on the air
and you know it it was such i thought it
was just so effective to put us back in
that mindset but also you know there was
the added thing with
that's who jimmy is you know of course
he sticks his face in there and he um
you know
drinks too much water too fast that
that's how that's that's how he
goes through life in a way you know
i think it's funny how he instantly puts
his piss coated bottle into the water
like before mike has even had any just
like completely contaminates the water
with his piss for mike like
i mean i guess at that point you know
maybe you're not going to care like
water's water uh but yeah i thought that
was really funny
yeah he he's been he had been drinking
that that urine for for quite some time
at that point so i guess you could
forgive him but yeah mike mike probably
didn't like it that's for sure harvey
willing thank you for the 50 that is
absolutely generous
pete gill courtney
thank you all for making this fantastic
season of television an even more
immersive experience i believe this was
before you showed up too that he he made
this chase i don't think he left you out
on purpose there
the full weight of his of this finale is
still slowly sinking in for me love the
appearances of mike chuck and walter
saul over now
yeah and i think i i touched on that
earlier too harvey that you know it's
it it's
i haven't fully processed it you know i
was um
i was working all day on the video
yesterday and
just had a brief nap and now i'm here
again and um
that was the thing when i was getting
prepared that i was thinking was that
you know it wasn't it wasn't uh it was
challenging it wasn't it wasn't like um
confusing it wasn't unclear
or incoherent i mean it certainly made
sense everything felt right
character-wise
but
it it just there were some things that
you know it just
it didn't fit into
the boxes of like you know what the
boxes you were expecting as far as like
what you get when you when you watch a
series finale you know like it did some
things that that were surprising in a
way
and yeah i think it i think the the you
know the some of the decisions and some
of the ways they were they got to where
they they were um it is it takes a
little bit of time to sink in and and i
i find that to be you know a feature not
a bug like i think that that that's
that's fantastic
brody thank you for the five my fa my
three favorite creators thank you guys
for
elevating this amazing show to even
greater heights with your great analysis
quite a ride well thank you very much
brody uh i appreciate it uh this would
probably not be half as good if you guys
didn't show up all the time um
you know gil and i started uh
the first week you know it it seemed
promising and um i certainly had a good
time talking about the show but the fact
that you guys show up every week and it
continues to grow has been you know it's
really made a big difference and um
probably you know
have people that would continue to come
because it takes up some time and um you
know
it could be a real drag if there if
there weren't a lot of people asking
interesting questions
thank you aaron stevens
for that australian 799 hopefully
a kim movie is made similar to el camino
set in 2022 showing how everything
turned out since the end of bcs
i need this in my life
i wouldn't i don't think you could put
it past them i think it's it's possible
but honestly i would like i know that
that vince gilligan has a show out there
that he's shopping around um they said
if
the the they're not there aren't any
really good
descriptions of it because nobody's seen
it but it sounds like it might be more
uh up it might be more similar to
x-files than than breaking bad but um
you know i want to i really really like
to see where he goes with that
um and i would like to see what peter
gold does next and um
you know you think even if they did a
movie
um you know vince left during season
three of better call saul and he didn't
get back until season six
uh you know after when he wanted to do
el camino so it's it's not it's not like
a
it's not something they can just
bust out in a weekend you know
it's a big process
getting it made getting the people to
work on it you know getting cast and
everything else so
uh if they i mean obviously like we said
i would i would absolutely want to see
more racyhorn as kim
but um
i'm also really curious to see where
they go next now that they have
not just one show you know not one
classic show but two that they that
they've
they've you know put out and they they
wrapped up really satisfyingly and you
know
that's going to open doors
thank you for the 999 mike johnson the
runner
austro1980 thank you for the two jimmy
turned out to be a pretty damn good
lawyer
yeah or saul i think would be the way to
to describe what was going on there it
wasn't all above board necessarily but
he was absolutely effective uh in his
ability to get his
get that deal uh it was an incredible
incredible deal uh one thing i loved
about the fact that he got it and i and
actually i think this is gonna have to
be the one i go out on
but one thing i loved is that i think
coming into the finale whenever people
floated the idea of jimmy getting caught
getting captured it didn't quite sit
right with me because i wanted to see
him make the choice to turn himself in
that kind of to me seemed like the only
path to redemption
um but they found a way where he gets
caught and then he gets himself a great
deal and then that gives him the
opportunity to then throw that deal away
and come clean and so i thought that was
pretty brilliant
yeah and then that was sort of that sort
of ties into what i was saying about it
you know like um
the other viewer asked like if i didn't
like the you know because i didn't
really want them to go into the court
and i really want him to thrive in jail
that was the thing like he got caught so
fast and i was like damn i wanted him to
turn himself in right but but as soon as
i as soon as i felt that and started to
process that they it was like it was
like they oh they're like we know that
this is what people are going to think
so now we're going to
hold on
he's going to get himself out of it
after the fact and then he'll turn
himself in you know what i mean i was
definitely thinking of you uh minutes
into the episode because we had talked a
few times about that how you kept saying
if he's going to go into the legal
system i feel like we'll probably leave
it off there and it's a little bit up to
the imagination we'll have an idea of
how it's going to go
um but but you and i anytime we say
something like that we always give the
caveat but if they do it i'm sure i
trust these writers to do it in a way
that would be satisfying
so uh so i think that's the case here
yeah and yeah and it
they and they have a track record of
doing it right they they do the
inevitable but they make it feel uh
exciting or surprising and uh one more
time you know yeah that's right
all right all right so you're gonna hit
the road
yeah yeah i think um as much as it's a
cliche to say it at this point it's been
quite a ride
and uh it's been a lot of fun pete i
really appreciate you organizing this
and inviting me on and uh thankfully i
think our tastes are pretty aligned so i
i hope that we can do this again in the
future with other shows and other
content um so absolutely
all right yeah like i said
in the past it wouldn't have been the
same without you so i i appreciate you
showing up every week and um
bringing a good conversation um
just like i said to courtney i'm sure
we'll stay in touch and be talking about
stuff and you know otherwise but
hopefully that like you said that we'll
we'll our interests will align so that
we can uh collaborate again because
you know do you know how the the
how it goes sometimes when you're in
youtube that you're just
just working by yourself and and doing
the next thing you have to do and it can
make it a lot it can make it a lot more
enjoyable whenever you're uh
talking to other people sometimes you're
doing that on almost no sleep so i hope
you get some sleep after this yeah
and that last thing i'll say my my
little brother's probably going to give
me a hard time if i don't do this so i
do want to plug uh you know to the
person who said that they're dying for
more better call salt content if you go
over to our channel and check out our
pre-show or our instant take that we did
last night
we shot a 15-minute short film uh our
own spin-off about lyle and if you
didn't get enough peter diceth in last
night's episode of better call saul we
got him back and we have a little
appearance from bill oakley in our in
our
unofficial spin-off so check it out nice
yeah i'll i will personally check that
out because i didn't i didn't see it at
all because i was working all day but
yeah that's uh that's that's great man
um definitely check it out
awesome thanks pete thanks chase i'll
talk to you both again soon
all right see ya
all right christopher dalton thank you
for the five i may become
a flamboyant con man lawyer in order to
cope with the grief of bcs ending top to
bottom beginning to end best show ever
yeah i mean um
i've said it so many times it's really
hard for me to say i mean it's my
favorite show right now that's for sure
and and it's it's it you could
definitely make an argument for it being
the best show
i totally get it but uh i i myself am
always cautious when it comes to doing
saying things like that because who
knows uh what i'll feel like
six months from now
but it it's been it's been fantastic um
much better than what i thought it might
be when it first came out that's for
sure
i made his army thank you for the 179
pound marie got justice enclosure she
didn't get in breaking bad
yeah i mean i guess she got the closure
part off screen
to some extent right because
walt gave
skyler the lottery ticket so
you know they knew where where hank and
gomez were buried so they found his body
that way
um or does that happen or did that
happen on screen that was that was just
implied right
yeah that was i'm pretty sure that was
just implied with the whole skyler got
the deal or whatever yeah because that's
at the very end whenever he actually
goes to see her for the most part
yeah chronologically so
yeah but um yeah it was nice to it like
i said and and courtney and gail both
that as well you know that
seeing her and
having her have that that moment there
it's a reminder you know it was a very
nice reminder and
it's really close in time too like it's
not been that long you know um
saw you know
walt just died a couple of months ago
and he gave her the the ticket when he
went back to albuquerque when that
happened you know what i mean so this is
all this is all still new information to
um murray schroeder like you know it's
not like she's been living this with
this for years um
it's still pretty fresh in her mind
mr 19 thank you for the 9.99 when he was
confessing everything he did it was kind
of like he was exercising saul from
himself
yeah i mean i i described it as in
killing saul but yeah he's he
he he was setting up a situation where
he couldn't he couldn't go back into
that he couldn't go back into that
coping mechanism and um
you know that was uh
that was very very good to see him
finally be able to get to that place i
just i just imagined like a saul goodman
ghost floating out of jimmy's body
oh my god
yeah
nobody thank you for the five could you
please invite ud
ud reviews to your live stream she has
really good insights
yeah
um she actually reached out and um
i was hoping when i when there was a
time when i was hoping that i was going
to get the saturday one going full time
and um
i was gonna include some new people and
she was definitely on the list but
i got busy and i and saturday i only
ended up doing one more saturday stream
so it kind of got all got thrown out the
window unfortunately
um
i'm not too familiar with the channel i
looked at it when she sent it to me and
um
courtney
gave her a
good uh
you know she she uh recommend you know
good recommendation i guess you could
say because they made a video together
that i saw a bit of um so i would say
check it out um
and
you know uh i don't know they're
you they're saying please invite her to
the live stream i i don't know if there
are any more live streams but if there
are
you know like she's definitely i'll
definitely be thinking about it in the
future
tin omen thank you for the five people
who hated the finale don't understand
brilliant writing
i mean it's subjective
i you know
i it worked really well for me um
that's all that really matters to me you
know like i don't have to i don't have
to be right about it um i i think that
a lot of the people that i talk to they
they agree with that
and i think you know what i i think
someone on my timeline said you know
they weren't sure how to feel about it
and i think if you're in that place
sometimes that can feel like
i don't like that i don't like this
feeling of not knowing how i feel about
it and i think if you're there i think
what you should do
is you should reconsider some of the
choices that they made in the writing
and how that and let that soak in a
little bit because i think it really is
some great writing um
you know but it
i can understand you know i kind of
prefaced the the beginning
whenever we talked about it i could see
how some people would be let down
because
it wasn't um
it wasn't entertaining in the way that
the show can be i mean i'm not even
comparing it to something else
i'm just comparing it to itself you know
like some of these sometimes it hits a
much higher you know a much higher level
of being just flat out entertaining and
fun
and exciting
that's not the kind of finale that that
we got so i could see maybe if some
people are let down by that but i don't
i don't agree with it at all
i do love how better call saul stuck
stuck to its roots and didn't try to be
something it's not or tried to be
um you know try to recreate uh breaking
badly because there's a lot of people
that thought that better call saul was
gonna go out you know kind of like
breaking bad did but that's not really
what better call saul has ever been the
show can can stand on its own to two
feet like it has legs it has a backbone
and i love how everything came full
circle of course everything's subjective
uh you don't have to like it you don't
have to dislike it um i definitely
really like the ending i think it's one
of my favorite endings of all time
probably uh recency bias you know of
course um
what did you see in the comments of your
videos were were a lot of people
mostly positive or was it split
what did you think
i think it was mostly positive yeah it
definitely did get a few uh cringe
comments in regards to that bus scene i
did see that floating around a little
bit but i didn't really see too much too
much hate i feel like some people might
just be blatantly trying to
uh you know talk smack about it to like
provoke a reaction or something but as
far as like genuine criticisms uh at
least so far i have to go back and check
again but i haven't really seen
cnn too much
yeah i i didn't see like an uptick in it
you know like i i i think that there's
been a a small on the on the small side
percentage of people who haven't enjoyed
the black and white
portion of this season
you know the stuff after
after uh the cartel
story wrapped up
but
um
i didn't see more of it on this video i
don't think i mean i i i've been seeing
people say for the last few weeks a
certain kind of person
that you know that this has been
terrible and that they ruined the show
which i think you know even if you don't
like it i think that that's a bit
dramatic
to go that far with it you know what i
mean
like it's still it's still even if it's
not your cup of tea it's still better
than than than most of the other stuff
that's on television you'd have i mean i
feel like you'd have to say that
objectively you know compared to just
based on the performances and the
and the set design and the
in the photography you know i mean it's
just that just seems like you're there's
something a little off if that if that's
where you're where your uh
where your take is is going but um
i didn't really see an uptick so far i
just i saw
most people liked it it seemed generally
positive and then there were some people
who who who weren't feeling it
roger rubio thank you for the ten
dollars what do you think was the
defining scene of the show which scene
do you think best encapsulates better
call saul for you
thank you for all your great content
throughout
this season and the years
man i don't know that that is uh
that's a question that that requires
some reflection i think you know we just
saw the last um
episode
i mean if you if you had to go knee jerk
i think you could probably say the
cigarette scene
or the two cigarette scenes maybe you
know
i was i was the gun to my head i'd have
to go with the uh the sunk cost scene at
the end of uh 303
i really like also
also a cigarette scene
yeah yeah yeah yeah
that is true gotta love it you know
vince always thought that cigarettes
made uh made made scenes look cool and
he definitely was not wrong
yeah
yeah i heard him saying that about the
jesse scene how they they put the the
rain on and and he had to keep smoking
cigarettes so he was like having a
headache or whatever aaron paul really
putting him through the ringer
yeah because it's pc said just nothing
looks cooler than smoking a cigarette
and it's kind of true like it
you don't really think about it like it
almost seems obnoxious at times but
it gives them something it gives the
actor something to do that that that
kind of energizes the uh
you know what's going on in the frame
even though it's like this bad habit
that that's unhealthy it it kind of
as far as just like you know
constructing a scene there really is
some some utility there
uh sorry i mean i i
i i would give you a better answer if i
can think of something i will but i mean
it's like there's so much
that comes to mind when you say that
that it's really hard to pin it down
moises
balbuena thank you for the 499. when
saul told his side of the story with the
prosecutors
it gave me walter's confession vibes
from the dvd he gave hank
um
yeah i mean that's pretty one to one
isn't it
i mean walter was
it was a kind of a different kind of
manipulation going on but they were both
uh acting right
well i mean saul even though saul is
like playing the victim card he's uh
he's he's he's mostly telling the truth
with uh with what happened well i guess
not technically because he he did
he he told the truth when who when he
went off the script and said that he he
had the incentive to work with walt but
uh
um i i guess he wasn't really too scared
of walt killing him but i mean
everything with you know getting
kidnapped and having a bag over his head
was real i feel like walt was definitely
being
they were both being manipulative for
sure i think that walt even more so
especially considering he was trying to
blackmail hank and frame hank for uh
for
the mastermind i think that was just
completely evil but i definitely see the
parallel yeah
robert k thank you for the 4.99 when the
episode ended shirts on hangers included
bcdc shirt does this imply jimmy
eventually got transferred to bernard
bernalillo county
um
yeah i noticed i didn't comment i i
wonder
i thought that
i didn't get a chance to go back and
check it but i thought that this was
what he's wearing this bcdc
that's where he is whenever they they
work out the deal
um
so
let's see like right here
this is what i thought was the bc
because you know what's her name's there
marie's there and um
that doesn't really make sense though
he's in omaha
they don't move him until afterwards
so i'm wrong i i said i never had a
chance to go back and and think it
through
that he wouldn't be moved to county
that bc is a county right that's like
county lock-up before you get sentenced
to to the penitentiary he's in federal
prison um so i i wouldn't think uh it
maybe it's just a
a kind of mistake you know
i'm looking at the uh i'm looking at the
scene of when he walks down the hallway
and he uh
notices marie right before he goes into
the plea deal and it does say dc dc
and then
at the end was that image you just had
up um
it does say bc so yeah yeah when he when
he sees marie it is a d
and then
uh the suit up conclusion is a b
so it is a the first letter is is
different
um i just
fact check that
it might be something that they made
promotionally earlier on and then
something you know
got switched and it wasn't really
necessarily um
they could have probably done that a
little bit tighter but i think let's
give him a little bit of um
leeway because i yeah i don't think that
you know if he's going to federal prison
that he he would never be transferred
into a county
uh
you know a county jail
that they don't work together in that
way you know
jack darquaris [ __ ] thank you for the
499. does this change how you view
breaking bad now seems like jimmy is the
main character of the breaking bad
universe walt would have died
in season three i'm happy for kim um
i'll default to what you know gill has
said he he mentioned this earlier and i
got the idea from him
in our in our live stream a couple weeks
ago that it doesn't really it doesn't
really
i i don't look at i look at walter white
as a force of nature i feel like he's
going to
the way that he is that if jimmy didn't
help him he still had a chance to rise
and and still do all the harm he did i
mean he was motivated he had the skills
that made that possible jimmy
facilitated some of that
and he definitely found him whenever he
was kind of floundering around i mean he
was going and trying to you know do
deals with tuko and the
and the uh
you know
the uh what's called the uh junkyard and
you know
he definitely moved things along and but
but really what's important is that
jimmy thinks that he that he was behind
it you know that that's something that
jimmy thinks that he's responsible for
so it doesn't really matter if it's true
or not and um
so yeah he believes that like what
you're saying here that he might have
died in season three i don't know if
that's necessarily the case
but um
you know as far as how it changes
breaking bad it changes it more to know
for me anyways to know that he's doing
that to deal with the loss that all of
what he's doing there is is an attempt
to not feel
the pain from uh what happened with kim
and everything that happened before that
and also now knowing after the finale
that he understands that that's what
he's doing and he's still doing it
anyways
sean perkins thank you for the ten
dollars plot wise it makes no difference
but the only thing i wish was the
original jeff got to finish his role
versus what we got with the new jeff
whose character seemed much easier to
bully and manipulate
um
yeah i mean i said this last week and
uh i'll repeat
it again just because i i you know
tom schnell said that they wrote the
they wrote the the script
for don harvey
um that they they didn't change it
whenever they changed the actor
yeah yeah so pat pat
yeah they they didn't make jeff like a
kind of a
buffoon for pat healy don harvey would
have had to play it the exact same way
yeah
yeah so that's what that's what i was
gonna say is so you know you're thinking
about it as in terms of the actor but
it's really
a character thing
that i think that um
even with don harvey playing him he
would have seemed a lot more incompetent
when we got to know him better it was
just sort of the way that it was set up
in the in the mall
that you know
he he he seemed like he could have been
a lot more
uh threatening or
you know
diabolical than he really was
big ralph thank you for the 20
uh the cost of redemption for jimmy kim
was devastating kept him separated
forever
walt seen continued the theme jimmy
can't help himself
the chuck scene gave promise to the fact
you that you can change your path
if you want
that's interesting the last one the
chuck scene gave you promise to the fact
you can change your path if you want
i i mean i i don't the promise part of
that i mean
what jimmy tells him is when did you
ever change your mind or change your
path or whatever and and the truth is
that he never did
you know he's kind of more open to to
jimmy at that moment in that scene but
like later on in the series that what
comes after is that he didn't he did not
um change he he went down
in uh you know
in flames um
actual flames after he just you know
tore his house apart
looking for
electricity um walt continued with the
theme jimmy can't help himself
yeah what i liked about what walt said
was that it wasn't true
he saw it the same way that
um that chuck did
but then in the end we saw that
it wasn't it wasn't correct
[Music]
and the cost of redemption for jimmy kim
was devastating captain suburb yeah and
i agree uh we we all mentioned this
earlier
it's very true
but
you know the cost of them not doing that
was also pretty devastating
and uh you know howard died and
more people might die as a result so i
think you know ultimately
kim made the right decision for the
right reasons and it's great to see that
um
jimmy did too that he was jimmy was able
to come back out and
we could get rid of saul once and for
all
randy shepard thank you for the 10 i
didn't understand how jimmy figured into
the strength of kim's affidavit
is one witness account much better than
two i can't think of how jimmy could
have produced evidence
um
i don't know if they ever really made
this clear in in
off the top of my head i don't know if i
have a really solid answer for this
and the reason why is that
i had some confusion about whether
[Music]
what jimmy was doing would actually help
him
and so that that's the answer that i
went looking for when i started looking
through the interviews and
as far as what peter gould said no
he's not doing it to help her get out of
her situation with cheryl
he's just doing it because he wants her
to be there whenever he gives his
confession like the whole thing
he he he said i i lied about her and
he'll go back on that and and they won't
be able to use it anyways um
but it was all just a ploy to get her to
be in the courtroom when he came clean
and then in the process he realizes that
he hasn't gone far enough that she
hasn't
that she's she's happy to hear him doing
what he's doing but but it's not enough
and i think you guys have both you guys
were mentioning how this is a mirror of
um
the scene in 410 because he looked at
the you know he looked at them and he
realized he looked at the people on the
bar and he realized this isn't enough
and he realized that he had to
you know give that impassioned speech
and start crying and talking about chuck
here he you know he
he realized that he wasn't it wasn't
enough to get her on his side and that's
when he brought up howard briefly
and then told the truth about chuck
yeah yeah i think
this question just also makes me think
of uh 612 with regards to uh
with regards to uh kim telling cheryl
that there's no witnesses that are still
alive other than my ex-husband if he's
still alive
which may imply that if
if
saul is still alive and he can be a
witness and corroborate that what kim is
telling is the truth and that would
back up her confession but the thing is
that this
that the question's kind of wondering i
think is that if kim is a witness with
no truth or with no
if kim is a witness with no evidence how
does having kim and saul being two
witnesses with no evidence really change
anything and i'm not really sure what
the answer to that is honestly i think
you'd have to have to ask a real lawyer
to get to get a get an input or do some
do some uh due diligence and trying to
look that up because i'm not too sure
entirely
yeah the thing he said to bill was that
i know something that they don't know so
i just assumed he made something up like
he said kim you know did something that
she didn't do
that that seemed like it was you know
maybe actionable but but they don't
really tell us like you said richard
seymour thank you for the five five
years from now a prison break movie yeah
i would watch it i would definitely
watch it i don't know if we're going to
get it but i would definitely watch it
dracarus [ __ ] thank you for the 499.
howard's widow can't sue kim
statue statue of limitations on wrong
wrongful death lawsuit and it's three
years in new mexico
probably why she can't find a lawyer
uh i mean i think that might be the case
but if that but if it is i mean i
believe you that you looked it up and
and that might be the case but i think
that that that maybe that means that the
show overlooked it because i think that
we're supposed to believe
that kim could be sued
and that she's shopping for a lawyer
because she's going to do that
was that your interpretation chase
yeah definitely and about the statue of
limitations i you know i'm no lawyer uh
i've heard you know through the
grapevine here and there that usually
it's around seven years for a crime or
something like that and uh currently
it's from 04 to o10 it's only been six
years uh so yeah i'm not sure if there's
different limitations for different
crimes like that super chat saying uh
but yeah that was definitely a thought
that went through my mind
uh during 612.
yeah i i like i said i think at the end
of the day we're supposed to believe
that
kim would
you know kim may be in jeopardy of you
know a civil suit but she but she's not
but she feels like that's okay like it's
you know i mean like she's willing to
um deal with that if it comes up because
she needed to unburden herself and and
tell the truth because you know that's
what
otherwise she was hanging out and
uh you know in the relationship with the
yep guy and and not able to make a
decision about whether she wants to eat
mayonnaise or miracle whip you know
uh
double dash thank you for the two take
on gold's lyre lyle friar for hire
announcement um
as soon as i hear that officially i'll
give you my take on it how about that
christopher nice thank you for the 1999.
when do you think jimmy made the choice
to tell the truth on the stand was it as
soon as he heard what kim did was it on
the plane was it spur of the moment
he was going by saul before he was on
the stand i think it was on the plane
um
or
in between one or the other it was it
was out
about kim and then he
finalized his decision when he talked to
oakley because he purposely said all of
that stuff in front of that agent that
was sitting beside him right
yeah i mean i guess if you want me to to
tie myself down i would say that he he
decided he was going to tell the truth
when he heard kim told the truth
when they were meeting with the uh the
prosecutors he decided that he wanted
her to be there and that he figured out
a way to get her there
after he heard about the civil suit on
the airplane
so they were both kind of spur of the
moment independent but he learned more
information and each time he learned
a little bit more about what was going
on he changed his plan accordingly
kevin scott bailey thank you for the 10.
i want to see a young kim spin off with
katie beth hall who played young kim in
the series showing how kim wexler
becomes the person we see at the
beginning a better call saul
i get the uh i i get the
i i also thought this might be
interesting not necessarily to use that
actor although she is great she did a
great job of being kim
but um i always thought that maybe point
putting those things in there might
might be
a fun place to go
but i i don't know at the end of the
series i kind of came down to
uh
you know thinking that
i don't really need to know that stuff
um
and you know now we're now we're out now
we're in a situation where they could go
forward with her story although you know
i don't really need to see that either
but yeah i mean i get the i get why that
would that sounds good but honestly my
take on it was before i really wanted to
see something like that and as we got
closer and learned more about her in the
final season
it seemed a little less interesting
yeah i mean i i
i could see them potentially doing like
a webisode or something like that with
uh with young kim i guess they don't
really do webisodes anymore like they
did with breaking bad aside from that
one kettleman deleted scene for season
three
um or bonus scene uh rather where we saw
uh them the kettleman's visiting uh
craig you know on picking up trash on
the side of the road
um so so i i think it'd be cool to see
them do like some sort of you know short
webisode
thing like
entails a better call saul or whatever i
think that'd be pretty cool
yeah i mean i i i would you know i would
not
there's no way that i wouldn't watch
something that they made that included
the character of kim or or ray seahorn
or
some kind of a
you know animated version of it but uh
i'm not gonna hold my i'm not gonna hold
my breath to think about whether that's
gonna happen or not uh rennie 180 hd
thank you for the two dollars what do
you think of
marie's
dumpster reference to saul
well they calling them a trash person
yeah i'm trying to think of what she
said specifically i i thought she just
said something along the lines of it's
fitting that you ended up in a dumpster
but um i could be wrong
what do you think
just kind of uh it's it's it's fitting
that you were found in a in a you know
dumpster because you are garbage type of
implication
that's possible huh oh my i sorry i'm a
little bit distracted here because
somehow my chat scrolled all the way to
the end
i don't know
yeah it's it's a terrible
terrible uh development here because now
i have to go backwards and figure out
where i was um
if you have anything else to add about
the uh
the dumpster feel free to do that right
now
i i was just randomly thinking about uh
i wonder if i wonder if jeff permanently
being left in the uh in the jail cell is
the new uh did hewlett ever leave the
safe house i wonder if that's gonna ever
be
be a thing um i i
i assume that marion is gonna have to
you know
maybe she'll let him let him soak it in
there for a little bit uh
but i feel like she'll have to you know
it's so it's horrible too because of how
stressed out you know she sounded trying
to help jeffy out with uh with his
troubles in albuquerque that she'll have
to go through all of that again you know
since uh since gene clearly
isn't going to help and that she didn't
want his help anymore um it's it's
really a horrible situation that he put
her in and that he left them in um
but my own head cannon is that marion
eventually
uh tried to uh or somehow worked the
system a little bit to get jeffy out but
that it was probably quite the headache
just like the albuquerque situation
yeah
man this is um this is
this is a mess here i apologize to you
guys um
thanks for asking so many uh
questions but um
it feels nearly impossible to scroll
back to where we were now that i got
bumped
um
i'm just going to click on the next one
i see and
we'll discuss that while i'm looking
because
i don't know how much further i have to
go mike pelosi you won the lottery
thank you for the five well thanks
everyone for giving us a little more
saul and consoling us just one last time
i've always looked forward to this chat
much love thanks um
right back at you
kind of fitting that i got a comment
instead of a question when i was trying
to solve a problem
but i do appreciate i do appreciate the
five dollars um
christian czech cone thank you for the
499 sending an immense thank you to
everyone that made
help make better call saul on and off
the screen
again awesome uh uh uh uh thank you for
the 4.99
and also thank everyone that that is
involved with this show but this is also
a
uh
another
statement instead of a question
gabriel samuels thank you for the five
why do you think there weren't more
nippy scenes
i don't really understand this one other
than
um
there never was a nippy was there
nippy doesn't exist i hate to burst your
bubble
but um that was all a ploy to
trick nice old marion into um
letting him into her home and into her
heart
oh how can how could it be possible that
i'm still scrolling back
more
one thing that i do think is interesting
is the uh the mint chocolate chip that
uh
that saul tries to sweeten the deal with
um is
it mint chocolate chip is clearly his
favorite uh flavor of ice cream because
not only did is that the ice cream cone
that he was about to have before nacho
kidnapped him in uh
502 and then he comes you know the ants
devour it in 503 but uh
in the in the season five finale and i
didn't even notice this until i don't
know probably like six months after
season five aired but i was like doing a
video or something and i was i i heard
jimmy yell out from off screen because
kim was getting a bowl he was like mint
chocolate chip and i'm like oh so uh so
seeing the ants devour that ice cream
cone didn't ruin that flavor for you
then and then even now
the flavor that he asked for i mean that
was just kind of a ruse i i think that
the whole point of it in 613 is that he
didn't really want you know the the mint
chocolate chip because he was just uh
i think he was just he was just saying
that in order to get what he wanted with
uh with howard and kim and and that
whole story but i still think that's
interesting how they how they brought
that up again
yeah
kenny jaworski thank you for the 4.99
channing on the bus is very similar to
chanting from jim jarmusch's down by law
which is also in black and white
maybe influenced it
possible but i mean that's one of my
favorite movies from growing up and um
i think it plays a lot different uh
i think i think it's uh
it feels spontaneous and and the and
everyone's involved in in a way that
that's different here here everyone is
um
everyone is uh you know
kind of putting saul into a place where
where he he doesn't want to go himself
so like i don't know um are you familiar
with uh down by law chase
have you seen it uh i i i don't recall
no i i do
the bus theme does seem like something
that like prisoners would do it it seems
like something that i've like seen many
times in like movies that involves like
you know prison um where they will
they'll kind of chant something or just
kind of have this group mentality of
like
i don't know it all you know also kind
of reminds me of like you know like a
baseball chant but um i'm pretty sure
i've seen certain like prison movies
where they they've sort of done that
thing before
yeah i'm sorry laugh i'm laughing not at
you but i'm laughing at the at the
scrolling it's ridiculous
i'm going to be here for for quite some
time answering these questions which i'm
very happy to do i'm glad that you guys
did this i don't know what happened here
that i got
kicked all the way to the end um
and all the time i've been doing that
it's never happened but
it's bizarre to go back and look at all
the ones that i have to go back the
other direction and
answer um
let's see
i think i'm almost there now i almost
have to be based on the time
let's see let's see let's see i need to
get one more
uh
because i need to step out for one
second sergio hernandez thank you for
the 9.99 why was walt's head so big
i thought he had lungs lung cancer not a
brain tumor maybe this is what gould
meant by you will see breaking bad
differently
i didn't notice it again i thought but i
thought they probably did better this
time because i noticed that at least
when people complained about it last
time
the uh the bald cap discourse
i i i heard from social media that
walt that brian cranston actually
potentially shaved his head for for this
scene in 613 i'm not sure if that's true
or not i believe that i would believe
that
yeah yeah it kind of seemed believable
it seemed like they might have learned
their lesson from el camino um i just
didn't think it was that bad i i don't
know it seemed like one of those things
that someone noticed it and then and
then it and it's possible that it that
it bothered you know like it there's
just a thing that you know that that it
bothers people like you know you have
some weird thing but like
overall i didn't think it took away from
it for me
yeah
do you guys think kim would visit jimmy
ever again um
i think it's definitely possible
we kind of answered this one earlier but
uh
there we're not supposed to know at the
end it's it's it's up in the air
i think she's just in case
yeah i think that
i think it's safe
so it's like when you're trying to try
to talk to someone on the phone and you
keep speaking at the same time oh my
goodness i was just gonna say i think
that he she will but she won't do it
without a reason like the next time she
comes back she she's gonna have
something to tell him or she's gonna
have something up her sleeve
yeah it's not just for fun and and the
relationship isn't just you know back to
normal or whatever john loskowski thank
you for the 860. how about a spin-off
show called superlab bcs made us realize
how much time passed from
when construction of the lab restarted
to walt's first cook
um that wouldn't be like where my mind
would go it would be more of a broad
thing about earlier in gus's
life maybe
um what do you think uh with the super
lab
that time period would that would does
that feel like there's enough fresh
stuff to look at there that um
you could get into it chase
yeah yeah so uh let's see here how about
a show call it a spin-off show called
super lab um yeah i'm not too sure i
mean i fee i feel like uh
i definitely feel like the way that they
ended it off in 609 was uh was kind of a
good way to end it off you know like the
way that mike and gus stare at each
other one final time and gus is kind of
like get to work you know we need to
start working on the super lab right
away
um
i did i do like it's crazy how different
you know the super lab is from
i think it's uh the season four finale
when gus brings gail down there to look
at it compared to the breaking bad
flashback when uh gail is helping uh
set up all of the equipment in there
i think it would be interesting in order
to er to see
um
to see something with regards to you
know the new crew that they hire what
happens to them but i mean like it's all
it's all kind of self-explanatory i i
feel like it's not necessary it's kind
of that issue with what a lot of people
had with uh with el camino like el
camino was amazing i loved it but
a lot of people feel like it wasn't
totally necessary and i feel like
there's a lot of stuff in better call
saul that they left out in the final
season because it wasn't really
necessary to show and that
they think the viewer because they i
don't know they
they uh they they they give the viewers
a lot of credit for you know being smart
and being able to figure things out uh
with uh you know how did uh jimmy get
the blow-up doll from the kettleman's or
how did he buy uh caldera's uh you know
contact book um
things like that uh they they didn't you
know explain on screen but we're left to
kind of infer how it happened um
so it's just there's a lot of things
that they could show or that they could
come back to or that they could have
shown but at the same time i think that
it's pretty
pretty self-explanatory for viewers to
kind of like fill in the gaps for uh for
certain certain aspects like that
yeah i just picked up on the end of what
you're saying there and it sounds like i
would agree um you know the
there's things there's there's tons of
story in there if they really wanted to
mine it um
but we can put it together ourselves so
is that where their efforts are best
spent you know i mean because these are
these are creative people that have done
great things and um
you know even outside of this maybe it
could maybe they could really surprise
us outside of this universe when they
didn't have the the same constraints you
know
all righty well it you know you said
that you needed to get going and you
want to step out here you want to stick
around what's your what's your plan
uh yeah i think i'm going to step out
now i uh i decided to stay stay a bit
longer after gil since i showed up late
i was uh i need to go have a nap
honestly i've uh i have some work i need
to do tonight and um
i only had like an hour an hour or two
of sleep last night and then like
another hour of sleep before the stream
that's why i hopped on late i was i was
like still crawling out of bed and uh
didn't uh didn't get my usual live
stream red bull so i i need to go have a
nap but yeah uh thanks for having me on
i'm glad i could uh
join you for this uh this final better
call saul stream uh if i'm sure you know
just like courtney and gil if our if our
taste lines up in the future i don't
know if you're ever gonna be doing any
sort of severance live stream i i know
that they released that show weekly but
uh
but it's it's like kind of like a
streaming service thing right it's not
necessarily so sometimes i don't know so
stuff like that there's definitely a few
shows in the future that we could
possibly talk about
um yeah it seems like everybody's come
around the severance since you know
since it's been out so it might be a lot
bigger next year
yeah definitely looking forward to i'll
probably be covering that as well i
might do something for season one
leading up to that uh you know kind of
like a refresher definitely definitely
something on my radar that i'm looking
forward to uh yeah well i'm sure we'll
talk behind the scenes with uh inner
guardsmen yeah absolutely
stuff like that but yeah thanks for
having me thanks
yeah thanks for coming out um
it's been fun uh
uh just you know echo everything that
you just said and um
i'll talk to you soon and don't worry
everyone that has questions in here that
i just saw don't worry i will be here
until i get through them all so we'll
get through this together all right
chase i'll see ya
see ya
all right
heen thank you for the 499 love courtney
pete kiwi and gil gonna miss you
pilot of breaking bad walt says
chemistry is transformation
bcs
fulfilled this idea that's life yeah um
i like that uh
i can't think of the actual wording of
it right this second but
i know what you're referring to and
it's fantastic and obviously um i've
said it before i'll say it again
probably several other times through
this i'm gonna miss you guys too this
has been a lot of fun
thanks for the 499.
um
serpentine thank you for the two jimmy
seems happier in prison than at cinnabon
i mean i guess it's relative uh
he's not on the run in in this weird
situation where he doesn't know
um
you know he doesn't know what's uh what
to do as a fugitive
he's unburdened himself he's come clean
he's looked at his thing so yeah but i
mean being in prison is still still
prison
so you know i don't know how you could
really say for sure which was better um
they both have some they both have some
big cons
although i you know i prefer him you
know being honest and and and moving
forward instead of just running
kenny jaworski thank you for the 4.99
what was the meaning of you don't
understand it's really good ice cream
it was just bs he just said that as bs
because
he didn't have a good explanation for
why he would do that he couldn't explain
to bill
in that conversation that really he just
wanted kim to come there to his
hearing so that he says that she could
see him come clean
so when he was faced with not being able
to have an answer he just said that he
liked the ice cream the ice cream was
really good
wall of object wall of text objection
thank you for the five thoughts on the
legacy of the show in the various games
or genres it played with law noir
westerns um
i think uh i mean that's a
that's a that's a big question
i mean i i as far as law you know it's
not a typical law law show um
i mean i watched a lot of when i was
younger i watched a lot of law and order
and
there was obviously a million different
uh offshoots from that
you know it wasn't really
i liked that i liked that they could
incorporate the law into the to the
bigger narrative without making it that
kind of show
um
and i guess you know when i'm looking at
this la noir westerns i think it's it's
it's more of a it's more of a show of
this time where there's a there's a
really conscious there's a really
conscious uh idea of
of blending genres and and not and not
going with one i mean that's that's what
i would say
maybe i'll think maybe if i think about
it a little bit more i can i can i can
add to that um
francisco chung thank you for the 5900
was the transition from saul to jimmy to
abrupt
jimmy had this enormous greed all his
life but gives it all up within a second
half of the finale
i don't know if that's really the case i
mean
i think it manifested that way
that he had this greed but to me
i think that he you know
underneath that he always had this thing
of where he wanted to be loved he wanted
people to like him
um he happened to be very good at being
manipulative and you know
running scams and things like that
and so he he went back to that but
i wouldn't i wouldn't say that it was
really it really came down to greed
you know at its core i think it came out
that way because of of the way that you
know
that manifested but
yeah i i don't think it was too abrupt
i think
i think it's an ongoing process but i
think that you know he can make the
decision that fast
esmen kim thank you for the 199 to the
fi did the finale change your opinion on
chuck
not not totally i mean it didn't
re-contextualize their relationship or
what i think about him um
i i think what it did more than that was
though it just sort of showed that he
did
you know the idea i always had was he
that jimmy was looking for love in a
place he couldn't achieve it he couldn't
get it
from chuck
because chuck wasn't capable of it and
you know jimmy kind of said it himself
in the court hearing he said he was
limited
and so
what that last part reminded me of was
that
in a limited way in the in the in the in
the way that he was able to
uh you know being the person that he was
he did he did care about his brother or
if not loved him you know
it just wasn't what jimmy or you know
maybe anybody would want
but it but there was something there
that's what that's what i got out of
that last scene
ralph baba ganoush thank you for the
five i think walt and chuck have a lot
of similarities and it subconsciously
led jimmy into working for walt because
he never got to work with chuck
um
i i don't know i mean they may have some
some some similarities but i mean i
think as far as what they showed us as
why he went why he was interested in
working with walt as one he really
underestimated him
as you know pretty much everybody did
including mike and gus later on um
and i think he thought that he would be
able to you know make him do what he
wanted to do and make a lot of money
whereas chuck he always knew that chuck
was was uh
was formidable you know
he always a little bit afraid of chuck
and i i don't think he had that in the
beginning with walt even though they you
know they kidnapped him and everything
else i think he thought that he saw an
angle there that he could play
and it all backfired on him
spectacularly lucas solari thank you for
the 199 the final episode lacked nippy
and pina colada song
it didn't really have a song it didn't
have that um
baby blue kind of thing um
but i like the choice i like that it was
kind of that that was kind of sparse
with the score at the end um
it felt fitting from from my point of
view
aj and nashville thank you for the 10
long time viewer first time commenter i
need to express my gratitude to
to you all for the added context took my
love of bcs to a new level thank you
especially to pete
you got a great gift of analysis sir
well thank you very much aj in nashville
um i'm glad that you decided to
make your first comment today because
you know it really made my day and this
is the last time we're going to do this
for a while
hopefully there'll be more i mean i'll
definitely be making more videos about
different shows i'm going to be
switching over to house of dragon um
house of the dragon hopefully that'll be
good but uh also if something comes
along and it's doing pretty well then
we'll be doing live streams again and
i'll be trying to bring on other people
to
have a conversation so thanks for the
tent
kevin scott bailey thank you for the
five taught college courses in a prison
the bus chant seemed realistic to what
my students would have done for a celeb
lawyer
cool
that's a different perspective uh thank
you for that
um
serpentine thank you for the two
spilling diamonds in the dumpster good
metaphor yeah i love that too i wanted
to incorporate that in my videos
somewhere and i just never had a chance
to hit it um
but yeah i i really like that too
oscar rondon thank you for the mx
220 hi all the only thing i dislike
about this finale was jimmy gaining 86
years he could redeem himself
confess his crimes and get the initial
30 years deal
why would you waste that he didn't save
kim for civil lawsuit
yeah i think that was the point um
he wanted to show that he could do the
right thing
just as she did
and he wanted to see her
he wanted her to see him in that light
and that was really all there was to it
um
it's not necessarily rational
it's kind of funny whenever they're in
there and she said you had them down to
seven years and then she just says 86
years you know
because that that's that's a big
difference um
but
you also saw on their body language in
the way that they were talking um
that it meant something to them
and uh and
i don't want to keep repeating myself
but it was enough it was that was enough
for him eric bray thank you for the 500
yen do you think jimmy
may have opted for the 86 years because
you know he
he knows he's incorrigible and would
just continue with his scams if allowed
to be free
i don't think so um
maybe on a subconscious level you know
maybe you know
kind of like you know there was a
question of whether he was trying to get
caught before i don't think he was
actually trying to get caught but he
sure wasn't not
you know he wasn't doing much to make
sure he didn't get caught
so you could you could say maybe he
maybe he was subconsciously trying to do
that
um
but i mean i can be wrong you know that
that could be there i it's not something
i picked up but i'll think about it
whenever i whenever i look at it again
crazy kid 2710 thank you for the five
australian bus scene was amazing
felt like a shout out to the folks at
okay buddy chicanery and how silly and
funny it was bravo vince
yeah i could see i could see people
liking it i just didn't it was the one
part where i was sort of like um
you know then and and it
and like i said it didn't take me out of
it it just sort of was like something i
had to sit through until
the much better part came after it uh
mark hogan thank you for the chf5
this ending and the final season as a
whole felt far more heartbreaking to me
than anything in breaking bad am i alone
in this the love story makes it brutal
um i don't think you're alone in that uh
but
i i think i don't know like i said i
haven't rewatched breaking bad for a
long time but i remember being you know
especially with jesse's story
being pretty pretty uh
pretty beat up with that one too and
whenever it's when it happened and i say
not that long ago i mean i i watched it
two years ago before season five came
out i watched the i rewatched the whole
series
the original time i watched it you know
when it first came out was a lot longer
before that but yeah i always thought um
i thought i always thought jesse's story
was pretty heartbreaking but do agree
that bcs kind of leans into that a
little bit more
piano orlando thank you for the five i
thought jimmy made it clear he had no
water
in his bagman track but last night's
flashback changed that he was just
trying to be sensational no i think it
just happened after they already called
um
because if you look at if you look at
509 whenever he gets bars on his phone
he still has the davis and main
urine you know filled with urine around
his neck so i think
based on the fact that he dumps that out
in this scene that just means that they
already called
victor is on his way to pick them up but
they have to still make it to the road
so they know they're going to be rescued
their trek is basically over
but
you know
i don't think it i don't think it throws
off the um the situation he that he made
it all the way through without water and
then they found some
and then they went to the to the to the
truck stop and they got their you know
their beverages and new clothes and all
that stuff arthur mueller thank you for
the r five dollars a better call saul
has taught you one important life lesson
what would it be
man that's that's a big one um
oh man i i don't know
that's hard to be on the spot with that
i wish you had given me what yours was
and then i could uh maybe riff off that
a little bit
i i mean
it would have to be something about
about character i mean about like uh
mask you know wearing the mask and
someone becoming the mask
but i i don't have anything clever
thought out and i don't want to leave it
blank air for for so long while i try to
to think about it but i'll i'll bring it
back up if i if i think of something
i ask you
hi
thank you for the five disappointing
ending season six should have ended
after fun and games
and gene's story should have been six
episodes long
to avoid rush job also with original
jeff
so you got two points here you think
that season six should have ended after
fun and games
running games but
okay so fun and games is 609
and gene
story which is four episodes it should
have an additional two
to avoid rush job
i mean i i hear what you're saying i
just i didn't really think that it
seemed rushed and if and if i recall
correctly it seemed like the big
criticism was that that that
4 or 6 10 was too long that they they
they spent too long doing that um
so i don't know where you where you pat
it out i i think it felt like it was
was structured and paced pretty well
from my point of view um
but
i hear what you're saying it might have
been nice to break the season there and
have a another one but um
in a way i'm glad they didn't do that
because
you know it had been like so many years
in between these last couple of seasons
that it may have started to feel like it
was never going to end i'm glad they
that they as much as i hate to see it
happen i'm glad that they were able to
bring it to conclusion now
and sort of go out on top nava down
south thank you for the 10 time machine
here
all good he gets
sentence commuted in 2024 and you never
know peter and vince will keep this
train rolling what character in this
universe
could continue
canonically well it could be anyone it
could be walt it could be marie
or not walt sorry skyler anyone in
walt's family that's still alive skyler
walt jr
marie um all of the side characters from
the courthouse
oakley
erickson
um
hewell is still out there he went back
to
louisiana though
i mean there's a ton of side characters
there's not really that many uh you know
kim is out there in the world
lyle's out there somewhere
i don't really i can't you know they
part of what this is impressive about
this finale that i didn't get to mention
until right right in this moment i'm
glad you kind of brought me
brought me around to it was
they actually
i mean think about it everyone's dead
and then you have the the conclusion
with jim and jim and kimmy are kimmy
jimmy and kim
it's it's pretty impressive how how
thoroughly they kind of uh
they kind of tied everything up
there's not there's a lot of things that
they could pull on like threads here and
there but as far as the major story
they did they really did wrap things up
tristee thank you for the ten dollars
did jimmy buy a time machine after chuck
died because chuck had it
nothing was was salvageable from the
fire nice way for them to tell us he
never stopped thinking of chuck even
though
they made us think he did
yeah yeah
i don't know you're right i mean he the
book is it did sort of just magically
appear in his his mansion um he could
have just went and bought the same copy
or it could have been given to him off
screen but yeah i mean that that was one
of my favorite
revelations from the finale was that he
he he did think about him
you know he he he had to work at not
thinking about him all that stuff he was
doing it when there was effort involved
with that it wasn't natural
dove's house thank you for the five only
quibble saul not knowing about kim's
prior deposition kind of ridiculous how
would he know about it though he was
hiding out as gene
they talked on the phone and then she
just went and did it
like right afterwards
and they didn't have any contact so i
don't know how he would know about that
unless unless bill told him when he got
there but
i guess maybe that's what you're saying
is that
bill didn't do a good job he should have
done he might he should have told him
because otherwise i don't know how he
would know
drakkaris [ __ ] thank you for the 499
trivia timothy mcveigh oklahoma oklahoma
city bomber was housed at adx florence
which adx montrose or monroe's is a
stand-in for
his last meal was two pints of mint
chocolate chip ice cream huh i didn't
know that
i i mean i know who timothy mcveigh was
i know he was executed
didn't know any of the other stuff about
that so very interesting
and really not a bad choice if you're
gonna if it's a final meal
to end on ice cream um
can't say i agree with anything that
timothy mcveigh ever did but
i kind of like his choice for his final
meal
mj 323 thank you for the four great show
even better to have found you for
yeah i i i uh i appreciate it um and um
even though i'm the only one here now
i'm glad i found the other three too
because uh
you know it's been
it's been fun to be able to to talk
about this uh with
different people and have you all come
and ask us questions
he who hughes
thank you for the five i believe this
was the first time saul and marie met
how do you believe he knew that she was
agent schrader's wife when he saw her
i'm not really sure
um this isn't something that i
investigated
uh
um the wheels are the wheels are turning
uh but i'm not coming up with anything
um
he did see her in the in passing and
knew her right away i i don't know off
the top of my head how how that might
happen
i mean
he
he could definitely know that from just
from being involved with walt as much as
he was but i can't think of a specific
instance that would make sense
bill thank you for the 4.99 what do you
think about
the cigarette they shared at the end and
the flame being in color i loved it i
thought it was uh on twitter right after
it happened i wrote that i liked it
the only color was that spark and it was
the thing that they share you know it
it doesn't make sense for it to go back
to color as much as that might have been
fun because
their world isn't the same it's not like
everything is fixed
but there is a little bit of light you
know there's a little that little spark
there and um
it comes from what they share together
from their connection uh that that
relationship that love that they've had
and i think that's awesome
ate my wheaties thank you for 9.99 the
way the shot of kim and jimmy smoking
mirrored their first scene together hit
me in the fields
the last semester the last symmetrical
shot of them in each in a cage but kim
gets to walk out of hers was terrific
too
yeah i mean these aren't questions they
are statements and there are two
statements that i agree with completely
um
i don't really have much to add to that
i i just thanks for the uh thanks for
bringing it up because you're absolutely
correct
andrew squire thank you for the 4.99
thank you pete and chase for the best
bcs videos these past years did any of
you all feel emotional the very last
scene with jimmy and kim
well we talked about this earlier um
i definitely i definitely felt something
but didn't get emotional which i thought
then was weird after the fact
and um
we had the whole of everyone that was
here we had the whole the whole um
you know the whole spectrum
from
from uh from where i was at to
ugly crying at least uh that's what we
heard behind the behind i can't remember
if we heard that on the stream but
behind closed doors before we started
there was some talk about that so
doggold thank you for the 15 australian
have you guys looked into adx florence
the prison adx mantras was based on the
misrepresentation makes the ending feel
contrived especially in a show about law
jimmy's prison life would be miserable
yeah that's why i don't know if that's
why they changed the name or not i
looked it up but you know i looked in
montrose nothing came up and then
in the regular google
results you get florence which is those
are two different words but the adx is
the same so i guess that's why that's
the most popular thing that comes up
i don't know if that's intentional that
they wanted us to think that because he
he did what he did he not only did he
not get seven years he got 86 years in a
really tough
prison because then you know it didn't
really look like that
necessarily so
i don't know i mean
it's not gonna it's not gonna ruin
things for me
uh
but you know i guess i see where you're
coming from too dougald
so thanks for that
james miola thank you for the 10
breaking bad or bcs is going to be a
godfather one two argument for the
foreseeable future
godfather one breaking bad has the best
lines an iconic iconic performance
godfather 2 bcs takes same characters
and tells more interesting story
yeah i wouldn't dispute what you're
saying there um i have heard a lot of uh
godfather two references
over the last couple days i think um
more than what i heard before this seems
to be a popular idea
and i wouldn't disagree with what you're
saying there about
the movies either so
thanks for that
gabriel samuels thank you for five why
do you think there weren't more nippy
scenes
i already answered that one um
sorry about that tyler hunter
thank you for the five one of you say a
nippy joke and i'll donate another five
bucks
this is uh
this is something that you said an hour
and 30 minutes ago and i appreciate it
but i don't have a good nippy joke and
i'm not sure
you waited around that long
unfortunately uh tom paba thank you for
ten i think jimmy's confession was
driven not only for kim's sake
i think she also inspired him to come
clean for his own growth health
not only for kim's sake i think she also
inspired him to come clean yeah i agree
she it's not really for his sake it's
it's more about
him wanting to her to see him do that
you know it's respect in a way but like
it doesn't really help her
and he was definitely inspired by her
doing the same thing
oops i already did this one i think
but thanks again mike pelosi
there we go
barefoot kings thank you for the 4.99
did you notice the level of sexual
tension between mary and bill oakley i
felt it was so fierce and tangible that
they could make a whole new series
i assume you're joking here because
i didn't see it at all but and and if
that's the case it's kind of a funny
joke and it would kind of be a funny
joke uh
series but
i'm not sure we should hold our breath
about that
hey mark thank you for the two even
marie thought saul in the dumpster was
fitting
yeah and you can see where she would
come from that i mean she doesn't really
know him but she definitely knows of him
um
walter edmondson uh you're bringing up
beauty reviews again
and um uh yeah i
i responded to that i as far as my
thoughts on her video on kim's pistol
hands at the end i haven't seen it
um i don't really watch a lot of videos
in general
especially not bcs because i don't want
to get influenced what other by other
people are saying most of the time so
even like the people who i bring on i
don't i i very rarely watch their videos
and i think they kind of rarely watch
mine
too honestly um
we talk we talk a lot the people who
come on we talk a lot
about things uh you know in messages and
things like that but so i kind of know
where they're coming from but um
i haven't seen this one maybe i'll check
it out thanks for the heads up
hands hands charler thank you for the
two dollars watched all of you for the
entire series thanks you're welcome uh
you guys make this a lot more fun to do
and comments like that
really help out because
you know get a lot of ones
that are a lot we got a lot i get a lot
of negative ones too and you know
sometimes those outweigh
the feeling that you get from the ones
that are bad outweigh the uh you know
the ones you get from the good um
doggold thank you for the australian
five i just wanted to say thanks to you
guys so easy to get bogged down in the
negative since i didn't like
the ending
watching season six would not have been
the same
yeah
awesome i'm glad i'm glad you uh took
the time to say that
friend francis francisco chung thank you
for 2500 what was the meaning of
cigarette light in color um
touched on this couple times that's what
i think it is i think it's the you know
the
the the the small amount of color that's
in their lives that comes from that
thing that they share
dual deer thank you for the two watching
kim cry and break down got me choked up
um
and this week or last week
i don't think she did she actually
full-on cry in this in this week
i can't remember
formula 444-888 thank you for the 4.99
any chance there will be another
spin-off i don't want the breaking bad
universe to be over
there is a chance
but i i really do think that you'll see
them go in different directions first
honestly um doesn't mean i mean they
have a whole staff of writers and other
people i'm not sure what the ip
how that works you know for this
particular deal
the the i mean look at some of the other
franchises that are out there um i mean
personally i'd like to see
gilligan
gilligan by himself or at least if not
gilligan and gould
at least be weighing in on anything that
was was coming at coming out if not
being like
i mean not just an executive producer
credit but like you know some some
hand in in crafting the thing but
you know it could they could go a
different way i mean there's you know
there's a lot of other writers that are
that are there that i'm sure would jump
at the chance to to show run
their own show
really cool thank you for the five maybe
do a breaking bad group effort recap
discussion like monthly doing one season
at a time fans us could re-watch long
one breaking bad season binge fest per
month um
yeah i'll think about it
i would like to
i'm thinking about doing some podcasting
in the future anyways and some of the a
lot of these things sound like i mean i
have a huge list of things i would do if
it wasn't like you know i needed to do
a video that was going to um
you know
pay my salary and
allow me to uh you know
take care of my family so
yeah
that's a good idea it might come out
more in the podcasting thing down the
road but um
i'll consider it
stones seven thank you for five dollars
people complain bcs is slow compared to
breaking bad when watching breaking bad
lately i realized first couple of
seasons were fairly slow
too unpair too unfair people to give up
in my opinion
yeah it's i i agree that the that it's
not as different as as
you know but i mean i think that
i think the thing with uh better call
saul was it was able to do a lot of
things that regular shows aren't able to
do
because
breaking bad was so popular and they
were coming off of that and so
um you know i think that
there's some there's some truth to the
the fact that it was indulgent in the
first couple of seasons
but it all paid off later so
you know people aren't patient
then they probably won't they probably
won't get they probably won't get there
it just probably isn't for them and
that's okay cereal thank you for five
jimmy's worst crime and the one that
makes him the biggest villain in all of
bb bcs is him tanking bill oakley's
biggest case
uh this is a joke i suppose uh
it is it is a bit sad for bill um
you know but hey
great character
and
happy for peter daiseth that he was able
to get a chance to shine and and a
really big episode of a really big tv
show because
if you follow him on social media you
can see that he's he
he's earnestly a fan as well as like you
know
really dedicated to doing a good job
when he gets a chance
formula 444 888 499. why do you live in
vietnam uh that is it's kind of a
personal question um
i mean
i i won't get into the specifics of why
why here uh
i sort of went
maybe i guess six years ago i left the
us because
um
i was doing some stuff online and i
thought
i would like to
i wasn't really that happy so i figured
i might as well travel a bit sort of
like
thinking i would be nomadic
you know and i did that for for quite a
while and then i eventually ended up
settling down but i i don't really want
to get into any more than that
on my live stream ces thank you for the
five dollars surprised how saddened i
was with the 86 year sentence
what do you hope for jimmy's future
would you want to see him ever secure
early release i mean i guess
theoretically um
it's one of those things where i went in
wanting to see
him
do what he did so it felt very
satisfying to me and i didn't much i
didn't i didn't put much thought into
what
might happen next um
maybe as time goes on i will
but uh
i was just i was just happy with where
they took us
almeida's army thank you for the 179
thank you pete gill adam chase courtney
and scott and yeah thank you uh thank
you for being here
i've noticed this name several times
over the over the last weeks and i
appreciate all the questions and uh and
the shout out for the mods scott is one
of our moderators and
those guys have really helped out in the
last couple of weeks and i appreciate
that too
and i would pick i would
post the link but i saw that scott
already did so definitely check out his
channel
david miller thank you for the five do
you think kim would make regular visits
to jimmy even with her life in florida
yeah we kind of touched on this it's not
it's not clear
she might or she might not but
um either way i don't think we're
supposed to know at the end i think it's
pretty pretty intentionally vague
and charler thank you for the two how
will you re-watch bcs breaking bad and
ec in order
i think i would do just what i already
did
publication order you know
as they came out
watch breaking bad then watch uh el
camino well
i guess that's a little tricky there
i feel like el camino seems natural and
then go back to breaking bad and start
the circle again that's the way i would
do it
jacques do set thank you for the 10 have
had wondered if this would be like end
of ozark main character gets away with
everything everyone else suffers
but these but the bcs writers are pretty
consistent people typically get what
they deserve
yeah i think that they might have even
kind of corrected a little bit between
uh breaking bad
and better call saul i think
i think saul got more or jimmy got more
a lot closer to what he actually
deserved than walt did because walt was
always going to die you know he was
always going to die even if he didn't
cause all the the wreckage and pain and
everything else that he did
so him dying at the end wasn't real it
wasn't really justice that was
inevitable so the fact that he got away
with everything
the more i think about that and the more
uh you know
the further i get away from the uh for i
should say go the further i got away
from the actual
event and the and the in the
exhilaration of watching that finale
the more it seemed like hey you know
what he got up pretty easy
he was gonna die anyway so
he basically got everything he wanted on
his terms
and um
i'm not sure that that
i mean i'm not sure you know everyone
always says oh there's no happy endings
and uh and in
the
the breaking bad universe his ending is
pretty happy and as as is as jesse's
and i guess on some level you could say
that that jimmy's is because he breaks
free from this cycle but
he actually feels like he has to pay a
price
um
going forward
not you know like in jesse's case you
could say oh well he already paid his
price before he was emancipated but
you know
it's all you know they're they're all
different situations danny thank you for
the five think i think there's any
significance to jimmy and kim sharing a
cigarette in jail cell like they've done
so many times before
i think it's their introduction it's
that thing that they do that is
it's super super it's like it's it's
incredibly intimate um
it was sort of a signifier to us that
there might be more to their
relationship in the first episode but
you know kim wasn't developed so they
didn't even really know what it was
and i think that because they used it
that way it it works really well here to
show that like this is our thing that we
do you know at h at hhm when they worked
at the at the uh
the mail room
and after whenever she became you know a
lawyer
that was their place where they went
and and it was just them together and uh
you know there's something nice about
that and the fact that they don't really
talk about anything they just sort of
kind of
it's like that one of those
companionable silences you know where
they're just comfortable being around
each other and and sharing that thing
christopher dalton thank you for the ten
dollars which series is better
bringing bad or bcs i say bcs i think
the writers perfected their craft doing
breaking bad and bcs was the result of
that what do you think
well we answered this earlier so
hopefully you got to see that um
you know i think it's an ongoing thing i
i think
you know
what courtney said about better
you know and and which one do you like
better is something interesting to think
about whenever when you think about this
but
these are questions you can't really
answer you can just have an opinion
about them
zdro thank you for the 199. love the cut
to the watch and the walt scene
yeah you know i that was something i
kind of had to look up because i was
like what is that um and you couldn't
really i didn't really make it out that
well in the in the moment but when i
went and looked at it that was the watch
that uh jesse gave him
for his birthday the one in between the
beginning and the end of the series so
[Music]
age 51 i guess
and you know it's funny because it's
it's it's something it's unnecessary
they didn't really have to show that
and um
not really sure
if it's supposed to say that maybe he
felt a little something about jesse or
if it's just
you know
he needed a moment there i mean i guess
he definitely did think about jesse
let's let's put that
but it we don't know what he thought
about it because that's the way that he
is you know he can't really imagine him
feeling bad about it
considering that you know he had the
opportunity to take responsibility for
his regret about gray matter and in that
moment in that short bit of time
he totally twisted around to make it all
gretchen and elliot's fault instead of
his own
gabriel ross thank you for ten dollars
did jimmy's testimony protect him from
civil suit no
and i say that because
peter gold said that he didn't say for
sure
but he said that you know it didn't it
didn't solve her problem and that wasn't
really the intention um
cheryl could be talked out of it maybe
she may not go forward but
what jimmy did did not affect that the
standard for criminal prosecution is
higher than civil suit yeah and it would
be hard you know it would be hard for
them to come up with something that
would actually make sense that he could
do there
because she went and she she went with
the sworn affidavit and and she she can
she uh confessed to her face to face you
know i mean it's
it's it's not in it's not really a
criminal matter there it's just
she knows what she did
but would one defend it be able to
shield another i don't think so
personally but i'm not a um
anyone that's familiar with the law in
any significant way
thank you pete kiwi courtney and gil
thank you gabriel i appreciate the ten
dollars
gerard kelly thank you for the 10 euro
what were your favorite montages in bcs
mine was jimmy's cell phone hustle with
street life playing followed by gene
feeding
frank cinnabon with the song
jim on the move i think it's a little
bit hard but i think that the cinnabon
one is is probably up there like the
other ones are classics you know that
i've been thinking about for a long time
but that but uh michelle mclaren really
really did a great job of putting that
together um
i always liked the one at the end of
season one uh with with marco it's
really got a different feel to it it has
like a um
i i don't know how to describe it but
but i really like the way that they put
that one together i really like the
score and the um inflatable
it's not the best uh overall montage i
wouldn't say but i really like the way
that that one opens up with the
the inflatable doll um
flapping around in the in the in the
screen and the way that they you know
the way they edit that together
uh i also
um
just looked at one of these lists of
of the best ones and i know i was kind
of in disagreement but i i can't think
of uh
what i would put above those
from on top of my head um
there's so many of them and they're all
they're all pretty good if they catch
you if you catch it at the right time
but i but i do agree with what you're
saying there
i think that that one and nippy is
pretty
pretty pretty uh up there on any list
after the end of the season christopher
walker thank you for five dollars most
contrived and kind of stupid story line
of either show
i would vote for the plane crash in
breaking bad kind of ridiculous i
thought i don't know i mean
it may be a little bit
all the things that have to happen there
but i just thought that was super
intense and um
i remember watching that the first time
and it really was kind of affecting
i mean i don't know how it holds up or
if you're watching it for the first time
now or something like that but
originally i thought that was pretty
pretty solid
most contrived and kind of stupid
storyline to be the show i mean i don't
know i don't really
there's stuff that i that i like better
than others but i don't really
i don't really have one that jumps out
at me
if it comes up
if i think of something i'll i'll let
you know
i mean i didn't really like um
the first time through i didn't really
like the the ted stuff too much i mean i
understood why they were doing it but i
thought
some of that was just kind of um hard to
watch at times
nip nick lemke thank you for the 999.
saul gone made me realize the gravity of
saul's actions in breaking bad my head
cannon had blamed walt for most of what
happened but marie hit home
that this is the evolution of saul's
schemes and consequences
uh yes to the first part my hand cannon
had blamed walt from most of what
happened but marie hit home that this is
the evolution of solid schemes and
consequences i don't think it's that
cut and dry i wanted to reread that to
make sure that that it wasn't
misinterpreting it
i think i think saul thinks that um
i think walt would if walt was still
around he would he would argue that that
was ridiculous and
we're all dumb for thinking it
um but
yeah i mean
these people are they're
they're all
really big they're they're all really
big personalities and they're very good
at whatever they do and um
those two coming together
you know
it definitely
made from except for some exciting
watching
hans shurler thank you for the two
dollars i was hoping to see marion get
reward money
yeah i mean
i feel like
she it was a mini york but i think that
she had a pretty good arc same with with
jeff i i didn't really need to see the
aftermath of that but um
i think they're all right i think
they'll be doing okay
i think marion is uh you know she got
she got some
she got some uh vengeance for for the
fact that he he you know he he tricked
her
hans charler thank you for the two again
do we
know when the chuck scene takes place
it happens it's got to be in the
timeline of season one a lot of people
jumped on the idea because he mentions
the financial times that
the next time he comes over he has the
financial time so it could be like right
before the first episode
but i i don't know if that's that's
necessarily true
it does have to be before
season one and i don't know how long he
he did that for but um i think it's
probably pretty close
sorry for the scroll time here
all right
seth thank you for the five dollars did
jimmy show up to his trial sporting the
blue ribbon for the plane crash do you
think it means he finally isn't wearing
it for a scummy reason
i didn't read too much into it i just
thought about that as him going back to
being saul and
um
he wore that for a long time you know
like in the in the
that was a big part of of of his of his
uh
you know his his suit for for a while so
i i didn't think it didn't it didn't
strike me as as weird that he would
bring it back out
so i did not think that it meant he
finally wasn't wearing it for a scummy
reason
i just thought he was accessorizing
there could be more to it but i hadn't
considered it at this point
i mean it's been a
i think that's something i remember from
watching i'm trying to put the pin the
timeline down in my head i know that
wayfarer was in season two i can't
remember how long he kept up with that
but it felt like
the first time i was watching it that he
kept up with that much longer than made
sense you know it's it
it seemed like there was the feeling of
why is he still doing that um
but i can't say for sure i mean the
whole thing of breaking bad happened in
16 months
and that's kind of wild when you think
about it so
it can't have been that long in his past
they shouldn't have stated his sentence
outright
um i guess there might be something in
us us guessing um but i think they
wanted to show you know
they wanted to make it explicit what he
gave up he had the sweet deal he would
have been out and um now he won't now
effectively he'll be in there forever
so what he did what he what he achieved
that came with he came it came at a
great cost uh jb 315 thank you for the
20 beautiful thing about both breaking
bad and bcs is the examination of the
relationship that comes so close to
working but can't
jimmy and kim walt and jesse jimmy and
chuck jesse and andrea
even jimmy and mike etc great endings
thanks pete and chase
yeah i i agree with that uh with
everything you said there um
you know there's there's there's in all
of those there's uh you know there's two
big personalities that bring something
to the table but they don't actually
they're not actually good for each other
whenever when it comes down to
it cormac dm thank you for the 4.99 just
a perfect finale saul had complete
agency in the end he wasn't forced to
confess he chose to be mcgill
chose to save kim and save his soul yeah
i agree with all of that except for the
saving kim part i don't think that
really figured into what what happened
um
may have come off that way but
i don't believe that's how it was i
think he did it to show kim that he
could be a better person and
he had to do that in the context of not
being able to get anything in return for
that
ron on the check thank you for the 199.
why did saul wear the howard hamlin tie
bar troll or homage
i think it was uh
homage
if you think about how he
er
i mean there's a there's a little bit
about
how they set up that his um
his uh mansion in in season one that or
episode one that kind of makes you
wonder
he had the um
he had a lot of stuff to remind him of
scams he did in the past
but i think with the howard thing
i think that's just jimmy wanting to
look rich and and and uh extravagant um
i don't think he
i mean giving how howard's story came to
an end i can't really see him
uh doing it for that for any other
reason
dirt pants thank you for the 199. we
never found out about kim's middle name
did we yeah she just didn't have one
a lot of people don't and kim wexler
didn't either
it was not a big
uh
it was not a big um
detail that was there for us to
stumble upon um
yeah that's all there is to it i guess
such in hj thank you for the 100 are we
tr are they trying to tell us there is
no going back to a life of color
as a consequence of his actions and
aiding
walter white
and all his actions
i think it's saying that i mean if we
wanted to get really specific i think
it's saying that
one act doesn't doesn't change
everything you know it's a process maybe
there will be color in his future if he
can find that in the supermax um
you know that's up to that's up to
to fate and some some level but uh
we'll see i i don't think
i think that what they're saying i think
that they had a choice
they could have had it come back and and
they chose to keep it black and white so
i think what they're saying is not yet
it hasn't gotten there yet
ron oden check
thank you for the 199. ian's guys are
awesome
you yin's guys are awesome and that
you knows go stillers
yeah
i am a steelers fan
that is my
that is where i come from
so i uh i appreciate that ron
scroll on that scroll here we go uh eric
rosas thank you for the mx50
just saw the finale had to wait a day
since i am from mexico ugly cried during
the chuck scene thanks for everything
pete
yeah the chuck scene
man it was good
at first i i was they they tricked me
whenever michael mckean said that he
thought they should that he shouldn't
come back because you know ghost is
if you come back too much then it takes
away from it
and then in the in the last couple of
weeks i was like man they really have to
have chuck in this i hope they have
chuck in this
so i was super uh satisfied that they
that they were able to pull that off um
just fantastic
and i'm a chuck hater i mean i don't
know
i i'm definitely
uh was never on his side
but
i like seeing a little a little a little
nice side of him at the end there
whoa what is this thank you for the five
when the prisoner said see i told you
it's better call saul i broke down in
tears in front of my two children it
changed my life
that's very personal and um
sounds like a wonderful experience
hockey king thank for the 199 what do
you think happened to walter jr
um
i don't know i mean i guess
he probably got the money
that's what they wanted that's what they
wanted us to believe at the end whenever
they had him go over there and see them
elliott and gretchen
i don't think that they had an easy life
i mean
when your father is a notorious uh
meth kingpin people look at you funny
and maybe the wrong kinds of people look
at they might look up to you because
they think they can get something from
you
it's not a good situation
crates clouds
thank you for the 199 don't remember any
other show ending with the cast
don't remember any other show ending
with the cast uh
with the cast i don't really understand
i don't know how to respond um
i apologize
lord friar thank you for the five i
think kim should have come out of her
shell more after jimmy gets 87 years in
a flash forward it makes make his
sacrifice a little more impactful
i think we saw though that she's on that
progression right
it's not happening overnight it's not
too fast but
i believe she'll get there
that's enough for me
david l thank you for the 9.99 imagine
the thoughts racing through jimmy's head
when he got to hold kim's hand after
more than half a decade of his life
crashing
thanks for all the content cheers yeah
it was they the the two actors did such
a wonderful job with that too you know
the way that they were both kind of
reserved
you know of course you want to see them
uh kiss each other or you know
jimmy sweep her up and then just have
that like just uh you know
triumphant moment where it's all
together but it's not that's not real
that's not what's really going on that's
like the
that's what we want to
see is going on and i thought that they
they really
navigated that the
you know in the performances in a way
that that really made it feel authentic
um
let's see thank you for that uh
let's see surinabus
silpi
tata thank you for the 4.99 do you think
chuck is happy now since jimmy
finally embraced who he is
i hate to break this to you but chuck is
dead
um
he's been dead since the end of season
three
no i i don't know i mean
it's kind of an end around on what he
wanted to see
he wanted jimmy to
to to not pretend so i guess maybe
there's something to it but he but more
than anything he wanted jimmy not to be
a lawyer like he was that was what
really broke chuck at the end of the day
everything else was just a um
you know was just a justification
billik e thank you for 4.99 did jimmy
will the good of the other
will the good of the other i don't
know
well the good of the i don't know i mean
i think he was inspired by what kim did
i don't know if that lines up with with
the framing you have there or not
mateo thank you for the hrk25 but i the
only one who wanted saul to take the
deal blame everything on kim and end a
show as a winner
you might be i mean probably not
realistically but i mean it
if you really think it through i don't
think there's much satisfaction in that
so i don't think many people i think
people might have that idea and then if
they think it through a little bit more
they might realize that um
it's not as satisfying as it might sound
gabriel ross thank you for the five did
kim get sufficient comeuppance compared
to jimmy given that she drove the scheme
against howard
yeah i think they both got a you know
she may be she may be paying cheryl for
the rest of her life everything that she
ever earns um
if not she definitely had a psychic uh
toll and and she she walked away from
the one thing she loved which was the
law
so yeah i think that they did i think
that that may be a little bit different
um
but
we'll see
arthur mill arthur miller thank you for
the r10
back to the life lesson question from
before to me it is maybe about noticing
your own patterns of behavior and avoid
falling into them
listening to the advice of those who you
care about
yeah those are all good things um the
life lesson question
uh yeah
i think you know i i i agree with what
you're saying here but i think that
that's what's really difficult you know
is
i i know for me i see things in other
people
and then i say oh i do that and then and
then i can kind of see it i i mean maybe
don't see it in myself i see it in you
know
someone else and then i can then i can
apply that
um
so yeah i think in i think in general uh
seeing your own patterns is difficult
but it is it is good it is a good idea
to try to see if you can can do that
um you know there's a there's a there's
definitely a a connection to what he
does in addiction and um
you know for him
the idea that kim had was that they
needed to be absent they had to be away
from each other in order for that to
work
so maybe in a roundabout way him being
locked up kind of achieves that goal
drakeris [ __ ] thank you for the 4.99
what would you change about season 6 and
the finale i'd have a full episode of
him being breaking bad saul much love to
the creators and fans we are a huge
family
yeah i think if they stretched it out um
yeah i think that that wouldn't be a bad
place to go
as as it as it was i think it was
structured pretty well
and i'm okay with it but
um
i'm trying to think if there's anything
else
i would change there's not much
um
i think they did i mean i think that
they did a pretty good job of laying it
out over 13 episodes
second moretto thank you for the 199
what is your overall overall rating of
the episode
for the finale i would say
letter wise it's probably an a
it's not a necessarily an a plus um
episode seven and seven and nine would
be eight pluses
and um
[Music]
i think this would be a little bit lower
than that
i thought it was really good but uh
it wasn't the same you know it didn't
hit the highs that some of the other uh
episodes did
it it did what it had to do and you know
sometimes
that means that it can't be the the
highest you know that happens a lot of
times if you think about shows the the
the episode before the finale is is
sometimes the uh
you know the one that that really
has the big uh the big payoff
abril alexandra thank you for the 99 do
you think jimmy kim will continue the
relationship beyond the finale i feel
like i felt like that final scene
cigarette was kim's way of saying
goodbye
also thank you so much for the streams
yeah i think it can go either way
i think that's somewhat intentional um
when we talked about it earlier
i had the idea more i didn't really
think about what comes next i just
thought more about the fact that they
got to a place
where they could where they could be
in that same room again because remember
she left him and she left him for a good
reason and she stuck by her guns and you
know i i really just liked that i liked
that you know he was able to
to look at who he was and and possibly
move on and that you know she was able
to uh
see that there was progress but
i feel like if their relationship were
to continue that it would it would it
would do so
and it's you know it's just sorely s
slowly build up to something rather than
just you know jump right back in full
blown uh passion
lord fryer thank you for i mean because
there's also that idea of them being
addicts you know so
is them being together is that is that
an act of relapse or could that possibly
could they possibly get to a place where
they could be healthy and entertain the
idea of having
a real uh a real relationship that's not
built off of uh
the scam and the and the thrill from the
scam lord friar thank you for two
dollars
not to say they don't love each other
because obviously they do we watch that
for a long time but just saying that
it also happens to be a component of
what draws them to each other is that
they they they really got off on the
scamming together
oh man a big daddy long legs just
climbed on my body sorry to hear that
lord uh
lord friar uh hopefully that got sorted
out it's been kind of a while since you
asked or since you mentioned that so i
hope we
hope that that wasn't uh a big
okay so i don't know how many times that
says no it says snow more than once
thank you for the 10. pete thanks so
much for all the content you did great
what do you think jimmy meant when he
says i tried i could have tried harder
not letting chuck's negativity define
him maybe yeah i mean i thought about
this for a while
it was the clip that i used to open the
video with and
i think
i i don't know i mean i think it's i
think it's it's something that what i
guess i'll say what i like about it what
i like about this
is it's universal you know it's
something that you can apply to yourself
and something that you met
like you felt like you could have done
better with you know whatever that thing
is we all have one if not multiple ones
where we you know like
regrets you know the time machine
question answers
and um that's what i really loved about
this is that he his character
he says you know i tried i could have
tried harder
and it could go
across so many different things but he's
talking about chuck
and um
you know i i don't know what his i don't
know what he thinks of as the solution
for that because chuck was mentally ill
chuck was uh completely
uh
you know set in his ways
and he was and he was out to get jimmy
specifically you know and um so i i
don't know if there's a solution
but i do understand what that what that
feels like to feel like that you wanted
that you know you did something but you
could have tried harder and and you
don't get another chance because that
person's gone
and i think that's what's that's what
resonates with me uh you know if you
have a if you have a specific thing that
you think that he can do
i think you could probably make it work
great question though i'd like it lord
fryer pea peppers how much
for
gail
better
gayle's dead
so
i can't say that i gotta connect for
that right now
uh let's see
lord fryer you're busy busy guy here huh
thanks for the two dollars walt jr lives
for his breakfast dies for his breakfast
so true
i think this means that we're getting
towards the end
we're almost caught up in the real time
here's one
james cassitelli thank you for the five
ed the disappear got busted too if they
found his card in the dumpster
which they probably did
that makes me sad
i guess that's a possibility it's not
one that i had considered um
he had a lot of stuff in that box would
that stand out as
what it actually is i'm not sure i hope
not
that's a downer that i don't need i like
that this had to disappear he was a
criminal that's for sure but
um
gotta love robert forrester and you know
this is a great he just played a great
role in this story
and that is
the last
of the comments
so i am going to get out of here we're
at three hours 30.
i think i reached my limit a while ago
if i don't see any more in the next
minute or so i'm gonna i'm gonna be gone
because i need some rest uh yesterday
was a really long day
and um
this always takes a little bit out of
you whenever you do this for a few hours
but um i want to thank
everybody i i really this was a blast
the whole thing
um
we got another one here
that chin
hj thank you for the 200 one of three
one third when the prisoners start
chanting better call saul i kind of
momentarily felt exhilarated
maybe jimmy has more exciting things
ahead with all the support and opinion
among convicts and accused
well i mean
i think it i think it serves i think the
purpose that it serves in the story is
to let us know that
he's not
he's not going to get murdered on his
first night there
but
you know like i said as long as it i
don't care if he if he thrives in in
prison as long as he doesn't reserve
revert to being soul because that's not
a good place for him i mean if this show
showed us anything that being saul as a
coping mechanism it doesn't pay off for
jimmy mcgill and it could uh
you know it could
it won't end well that's the thing it
won't end well even if even if he starts
to get ahead and it looks
good nothing good will come out of it
and um
one of three i don't really understand
this does that mean that there's another
one coming because i only see one not
two uh
and third when the because i don't it
doesn't make sense with the sentence if
it was just
it's the thing so i don't know if you if
you have a follow-up for this now's the
time because
i'm really i'm i'm running out of gas
here
oh there's one travis nova let me take a
sip before
my big takeaway was chuck's message to
jimmy about regrets
it's never too late to change your path
yeah
it's a good one
it's not it's not something i keyed on
in the first watch because of the fact
that he turns it around on him he says
when did you ever change your path you
know
but
you're right it
that's what we saw play out so it's it's
cool i enjoy it
um a.d acevedo thank you for the five i
really think they
purposely played on the whole breaking
bad theme and made this breaking good
man
yeah i mean i guess
you could say that
it's a little on the nose but uh
it doesn't mean it's not true
christian driscoll thank you for the 25
that is very
generous and i appreciate it um thank
you so much for these live streams and
your recaps i've enjoyed it so much and
yeah thank you uh
i think that
i see you in the mention or in the uh
notifications in twitter quite a bit and
i appreciate that too
it's really humbling to have people who
show up every week like i've said
it's great fun
i feel lucky and uh you know i work
pretty hard on this stuff so i feel
like you know
it gives me a reason to to continue to
do that and to feel good about it so i
appreciate it
sanction hj
thank you for the hundred but then i
realized it is against where he is now
he wants to be jimmy mcgill and not saul
goodman all right so is this two or
three hmm
one of three said
they're chanting
ah
yes
yes we're in agreement
that's what i was saying whenever i read
your first one
sachin that um i i don't care if he
thrives i want him to be jimmy he he
does that and they turn you know he says
that i'm jimmy and they say saul and you
see it later when he's cooking the bread
that they call him saul again so
yeah as long as it as long as they're
not you know as long as he he's still be
he's able to still pursue that then
it is what it is you know you have to
survive that's that's the nature of
prison right you don't you're not free
um you got to deal with a lot of stuff
none of it none of it's good
lord fryer
thank you for the two show was great but
a little heavy on coincidence
um i mean maybe that's valid but um
i think it avoided being you know having
things that were completely contrived i
think it did pretty good
relatively
nothing's perfect i wouldn't say that
this show is either but um
i really enjoy it and uh you know they
really um
deserve
everything good that comes to them
because they
they pulled off
an amazing uh
thing by bringing this to the series to
completion
and with that
oh samson there's your three out of
three whatever man a very sad and
sobering moment for me
karma gets you
oh now i don't know what the connection
is here
yes i'm following what you're saying
there that's what i said you know that
even though he wants to be jimmy
they want him to be saul
but i mean it's not it
but what what we're seeing doesn't match
up with that uh
you know if it's bringing you down in
there like
you see that that's happening but you
see that he's still resisting it you
know what i mean like nobody's making
him be saul goodman um
i don't feel like that's the i don't
feel like that's the story there i feel
like the story is that
he can't escape it not that easy not
that clean
but he can still he can still choose to
be jimmy
so
all right guys i'm gonna get out of here
now
i appreciate everything
it's been a blast
please continue to follow my channel and
that you know i put every i i do every
show just about the same i try to put
everything i can into it and um
if you like the shows that i'm watching
or if you haven't heard of them maybe
check them out and maybe we can watch it
together
and i'm going to leave you with that
thanks for watching and i'll talk to you
soon